Hello. Welcome to your second drink of Prince Family Paper.
Angela, you started this podcast breakdown, like our original breakdown with a gripe.
I did?
Yes.
What did I say?
Okay, it was about a magazine that had put you in a side-by-side of who wore it best.
That's so tacky.
I know.
你好。欢迎来到《办公室》第二杯。安吉拉，你开启这个播客的拆解方式，就像我们最初的拆解一样，是从一个抱怨开始的。我吗？是的。我说什么了？好吧，那是关于一本杂志把你放在了“谁穿得更好看”的对比栏里。那太俗气了。我知道。
We discussed.
Well, in honor of that gripe, I'd like to start this second drink.
drink with a similar gripe.
Were you in a side-by-side?
No.
I wasn't in a side-by-side.
Okay.
But People Magazine did me dirty, lady.
我们讨论过。好吧，为了纪念那个抱怨，我想用一个类似的抱怨来开启这第二杯。你被放在对比栏里了吗？没有。我没有被放在对比栏里。好吧。但是《人物》杂志对我太刻薄了，女士。
I'm calling them out.
They did me dirty.
What would they do?
Okay.
I get a text from my brother-in-law.
He sends me a photo.
He had bought a People Magazine because he was getting on a flight.
Okay.
我要公开指责他们。他们对我太刻薄了。他们做了什么？好吧。我收到姐夫发来的短信。他给我发了一张照片。他买了一本《人物》杂志，因为他要坐飞机。好吧。
And he was all excited because he was like,
Jenna, I'm on a flight and I opened my People magazine.
And here you are.
Oh, that's fun.
You think it would be fun.
But People Magazine did me dirty.
What the hell did they do?
Okay.
他很兴奋，因为他说，珍娜，我在飞机上，我打开了《人物》杂志。然后你就在这里。哦，那很有趣。你以为会很有趣。但《人物》杂志对我太刻薄了。他们到底做了什么？好吧。
They took a quote that I said back in, I think, like, 2018, like a while ago.
Yeah.
This is an old quote that they're recycling.
Okay.
Slow Newsday.
We're digging back into 2018.
So it says,
With younger generations binge watching 2000s hit The Office on Netflix, on Netflix,
他们引用了我大概在2018年说的一句话，很久以前了。是的。这是一句他们正在回收利用的旧话。好吧。新闻淡季。我们正在挖掘2018年的旧闻。所以上面写着，随着年轻一代在Netflix上刷剧《办公室》，Netflix上，
the 52-year-old is thrilled to be reaching new audiences.
Not so thrilling when she's shopping at Target and is approached by a teen.
Quote, they'll say, you know what?
Does anyone like tell you that you look like an older version of that girl from the office?
When Jenna explains that she has to be a woman.
actually did play Pam Beasley on the show, quote, sometimes they don't even believe me, she told Conan O'Brien, quote. Oh my God. This is some from so long ago. I know. This is back when Conan O'Brien had a talk show. Good night. And then I say they're like, no, but you do look like her. So I remember telling this funny story. That doesn't do me dirty. That's fine. That's a funny story that I told. Sure, People magazine, you want to recycle a snippet from an.
interview from 2018. Fine. We'll let you. Fine. Fine. But then what? But here's what they did, lady.
They found an unflattering low angle photo of me. Why did they do that? Why? And then, and then here's
这位52岁的人很高兴能接触到新的观众。但当她在塔吉特购物时被一个青少年搭讪时，就不那么令人兴奋了。引用，他们会说，你知道吗？有人跟你说过你长得像《办公室》里那个女孩的老年版吗？当珍娜解释说她必须是一个女人时。实际上确实在剧中扮演了帕姆·比斯利，引用，有时他们甚至不相信我，她告诉柯南·奥布莱恩，引用。天哪。这是很久以前的事了。我知道。这是柯南·奥布莱恩还有脱口秀的时候。晚安。然后我说他们就像，不，但你确实长得像她。所以我记得讲了这个有趣的故事。那并没有对我刻薄。没关系。那是我讲的一个有趣的故事。当然，《人物》杂志，你想回收利用2018年采访中的片段。好吧。我们让你用。好吧。好吧。但后来呢？但这就是他们所做的，女士。他们找了一张我角度很低、不好看的照片。他们为什么要那样做？为什么？然后，然后这就是
the other thing. I know this photo. This is from before I was wearing glasses. And I was like,
wait, that's a kind of older photo at like a very unflattering angle. And I,
I think they put a filter on this photo to make me look worse.
Come on.
Lady.
Do you have the original?
Do you have a side by side of your original and then their mock-up?
You know I do, lady, because you know I love a side-by-side and I am a mom detective.
另一件事。我知道这张照片。这是在我戴眼镜之前拍的。我当时想，等等，那是一张比较旧的照片，角度非常不好看。而且我，我觉得他们给这张照片加了滤镜，让我看起来更糟。得了吧。女士。你有原图吗？你有你的原图和他们修改后的对比图吗？你知道我有，女士，因为你知道我喜欢对比，而且我是一个妈妈侦探。
And look at the difference.
This is the original photo.
This is the did me dirty.
They put a filter on it to create all these shadows and deep lines.
on my face.
What's that about?
I don't know.
Do you have like an ex-boyfriend at Pupil-Mex?
看看区别。这是原图。这就是对我刻薄的地方。他们给它加了滤镜，在我的脸上制造了所有这些阴影和深纹。那是怎么回事？我不知道。你是不是在《人物》杂志社有个前男友？
I don't know.
But like, I'm sorry.
That's messed up.
Mm-hmm.
Well, it's always crazy to me, too, how they, it seems like they pick the most
unflattering picture of you out there.
It's like, you know there's better pictures.
我不知道。我不知道。但就像，我很抱歉。这太糟糕了。嗯。好吧，他们总是挑选你最不好看的照片，这对我来说也很疯狂。就像，你知道有更好的照片。
Why are you picking that one?
Like, what is that snarkiness about?
And you know what else?
What?
Every single time there's anything about me and Josh, they always print my age.
I'm like, we get it.
I'm six years older than him.
We get it.
你为什么要选那一张？那种刻薄是为了什么？你还知道什么吗？每次有关于我和乔什的任何报道，他们总是印我的年龄。我就想，我们懂了。我比他大六岁。我们懂了。
Well, here's something that I remember is that when I've had my photo taken by the New York Times,
because that's happened a few times, a little bit of a flex.
Okay.
We did it, Angela.
New York Times took our photo twice.
And they do not edit it in any way.
That's a journalistic integrity.
So that picture of you is exactly as it is the day they took it.
好吧，我记得的一件事是，当我的照片被《纽约时报》拍摄时，因为这种情况发生过几次，稍微有点炫耀。好吧。我们做到了，安吉拉。纽约时报拍了我们两次照片。而且他们没有任何编辑。那是新闻诚信。所以那张你的照片和你被拍那天一模一样。
There's no filter.
No filter, no Photoshop.
They made that very clear.
Lady, I remember when they came to my house to take our picture and they told us that.
And we moved two of my kitchen stools out onto my front lawn in front of my hedge where I have really good light.
Because they also don't bring like bounce boards and stuff.
They're like, we're taking it.
It's a photo journalistic photo.
没有滤镜。没有滤镜，没有Photoshop。他们说得很清楚。女士，我记得他们来我家给我们拍照时，他们告诉了我们这一点。我们把两张厨房凳子搬到了前草坪上，放在树篱前，那里光线很好。因为他们也不带反光板之类的东西。他们说，我们要拍了。这是一张摄影新闻照片。
We were like, okay, can we at least take it in a place with really great light?
Yeah.
And they said yes.
So anyway, okay.
Well, moving on to Prince Family Paper, we have discussed how this is a major cringe episode.
Yeah.
It's my personal number one skip it episode.
I just, I can't take the hot or not debate.
我们当时想，好吧，我们至少可以在光线很好的地方拍吗？是的。他们说是的。所以无论如何，好吧。继续讲《普林斯家族纸业》，我们已经讨论过这是一集非常尴尬的剧集。是的。这是我个人排名第一的跳过剧集。我只是，我受不了“火辣还是不火辣”的辩论。
I can't take the Prince family demise.
We got mail on both sides of this.
argument on skip it or love it. So first up from Miranda D in Australia, Miranda says, I got to say, ladies,
this is a skipit for me. I recently listened to your first conversation with Billy Elish and learned
it's a skipit episode for her too. The actors who play the Prince family paper owners do such an
amazing job of portraying genuinely sweet business owners and I feel so bad every time I watch it.
But that's not to say there aren't some great scenes in this episode, such as the
cold open, which is one of my favorite gym pranks.
我受不了普林斯家族的倒闭。我们收到了关于这个争论双方的来信，关于跳过还是喜爱。首先是来自澳大利亚的米兰达·D，米兰达说，我得说，女士们，这一集对我来说是跳过。我最近听了你们和比莉·艾利什的第一次谈话，了解到这对她来说也是一集跳过。扮演普林斯家族纸业老板的演员们在塑造真正善良的企业主方面做得非常出色，每次我看的时候我都感到非常难过。但这并不是说这一集中没有一些很棒的场景，比如冷开场，这是我最喜欢的吉姆恶作剧之一。
Well, you know, Miranda, thank you for writing in.
I know there's a lot to be discussed here, but I still get excited when you say
Billy Elish's first conversation because that meant there was a second.
Sorry.
I know that's not the point of this conversation.
Okay, moving on.
We also got a letter from Layton R in California.
Leighton, you've written us many times.
好吧，你知道，米兰达，谢谢你的来信。我知道这里有很多可以讨论的地方，但我听到你说比莉·艾利什的第一次谈话时仍然很兴奋，因为这意味着有第二次。抱歉。我知道那不是这次谈话的重点。好吧，继续。我们还收到了来自加利福尼亚州雷顿·R的信。雷顿，你给我们写过很多次信。
Thank you so much.
Layton said I ranked this episode high on the list. My favorite scene was when Michael hits his car against the curb and the Prince family comes outside and helps him. And here's what really stands out. It's how nice their family tends to be, despite Michael and Dwight's surveillance and attempts to shut them down. I appreciated the scene because it shows how Michael feels guilty. And then he realizes how he might feel. He is hurting those genuinely great people and this family that really really.
works to keep their business open and it just makes their situation more serious. So I guess
Layton really liked all the complexity there. It is a complex episode. This is true. And it doesn't
end how you think it will, which is, I mean, every time this episode comes up, I'm like, I can't
believe we shut down the little family run paper place. I know. It's really difficult. It's really
difficult. Well, finally, we got this letter from Miranda J and Wake Forest, North Carolina,
who said, I love how strongly Michael and Dwight each feel about Denny's versus IHOP.
非常感谢。雷顿说我把这一集排在名单的前列。我最喜欢的场景是迈克尔把车撞到路边，普林斯一家出来帮助他的时候。真正突出的是，尽管迈克尔和德怀特进行了监视并试图让他们倒闭，但他们的家庭依然非常友善。我很欣赏这个场景，因为它展示了迈克尔是如何感到内疚的。然后他意识到他可能会有什么感觉。他正在伤害那些真正伟大的人，这个家庭真的非常努力地维持他们的生意，这让他们的处境变得更加严重。所以我猜雷顿真的很喜欢其中的复杂性。这是一集复杂的剧集。这是真的。而且结局不像你想象的那样，我的意思是，每次这一集出现时，我都想，我不敢相信我们让那家小型家族纸业公司倒闭了。我知道。这真的很困难。这真的很困难。好吧，最后，我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州威克森林市米兰达·J的这封信，她说，我喜欢迈克尔和德怀特对丹尼餐厅和IHOP各自的强烈感受。
I must know the opinions of the office ladies, which side are y'all on? Personally, I agree with
Dwight. Denny's is the OG, literally beat IHop by five years. Well, lady, before we say, if we're
Denny's or IHop, let's listen to this argument.
and Dwight are in the car, and it starts with them going over their plans for their alter egos.
Okay, so let's go over the plan again.
All right.
I am a local business owner.
I need to buy paper.
我必须知道《办公室》女士们的意见，你们站在哪一边？就我个人而言，我同意德怀特。丹尼餐厅是鼻祖，实际上比IHOP早了五年。好吧，女士，在我们说我们是丹尼餐厅还是IHOP之前，让我们听听这个争论。和德怀特在车里，开始时他们正在讨论他们的化身计划。好吧，让我们再过一遍计划。好的。我是一个当地的企业主。我需要买纸。
I find out everything about their prices and policies.
You're a fictitious name?
Michael Scarn.
Good.
I am a paper salesman looking for a new job.
I find out everything about their expenses and salaries.
Okay.
Then we meet at the Denny's, and we compare notes.
我找出关于他们价格和政策的一切。你是一个虚构的名字？迈克尔·斯卡恩。好。我是一个寻找新工作的纸张推销员。我找出关于他们开支和薪水的一切。好吧。然后在丹尼餐厅见面，我们比较笔记。
No, I never said Denny's.
I hop.
No.
I said Denny.
You know how I feel about eye hop.
Don't start.
Socialist.
don't want to get into this debate again.
不，我从来没说过丹尼餐厅。IHOP。不。我说的是丹尼。你知道我对IHOP的感觉。别开始。社会主义者。不想再卷入这场辩论了。
Okay.
I enjoy IHOP.
I'll have a cup of coffee.
You will have pancakes and you'll like it.
So, lady, do you have strong feelings between Denny's and IHop?
I do not.
I love a nice big old, like, kind of diner breakfast.
Jenna, one of my favorite things is when you and I take a trip to New York, we go to a diner
好吧。我喜欢IHOP。我会喝杯咖啡。你会吃煎饼，而且你会喜欢的。所以，女士，你在丹尼餐厅和IHOP之间有强烈的感情吗？我没有。我喜欢一顿不错的大餐，就像，那种餐馆早餐。珍娜，我最喜欢的事情之一就是当你和我去纽约旅行时，我们去一家餐馆
and we have a big old breakfast together.
And I just love it.
My dad loved like a big breakfast.
And I think it just makes me think of him.
So I'm sorry to be a lameo, but I don't care one or the other.
They seem interchangeable to me.
Is that bad?
Oh, well, this is Michael's point.
我们一起吃一顿丰盛的早餐。我只是很喜欢它。我爸爸喜欢那种丰盛的早餐。我想这让我想起了他。所以很抱歉做一个无聊的人，但我不在乎哪一个。它们对我来说似乎是可以互换的。那很糟糕吗？哦，好吧，这就是迈克尔的观点。
Like, we can go to either one of these, but we're going where I want and you're going to like it.
So what is yours?
You know, if you forced me to pick one, if you were like, you can only go to one of these two places for the rest of your life, I think I would have to pick Denny's.
Really? Well, we have a Denny's near our house. We don't have an IHOP near her house and we go to Denny's.
So for a very long time, the Denny's by our house, kids eat free on Tuesdays. And they have a claw machine. And it was like, it was a great place to go like go out to dinner with little kids especially, you know? Yeah. And you could have breakfast for dinner at Denny's like the kids could. They've got a chicken and waffles.
But they've also got a really nice.
They've added like a nice, like rice and protein bowl.
Can you tell I eat it, Denny's quite a bit?
就像，我们可以去这两个地方中的任何一个，但我们要去我想去的地方，你会喜欢的。那么你的呢？你知道，如果你强迫我选一个，如果你说，你余生只能去这两个地方中的一个，我想我不得不选丹尼餐厅。真的吗？好吧，我们家附近有一家丹尼餐厅。我们家附近没有IHOP，我们去丹尼餐厅。所以很长一段时间以来，我们家旁边的丹尼餐厅，周二孩子们免费吃。而且他们有一个抓娃娃机。这就像，这是一个带小孩子出去吃晚餐的好地方，特别是，你知道吗？是的。而且你可以在丹尼餐厅吃早餐当晚餐，就像孩子们可以那样。他们有鸡肉和华夫饼。但他们也有一个非常好的。他们增加了一些不错的，比如米饭和蛋白质碗。你能看出我经常在丹尼餐厅吃吗？
I was going to say, you are pretty versed in this menu.
Yeah, I mean, I lived near an I hop when I first moved to L.A.
And I could walk to it.
And that's back when my car used to break down all the time.
Remember my car that broke down during Booz Cruise?
Yes.
And I finally got a new car.
So there were many times where I was just like,
我正想说，你对这个菜单很精通。是的，我的意思是，我刚搬到洛杉矶时住在一家IHOP附近。我可以步行去那里。那是我车经常坏的时候。还记得我在《酒水巡游》期间坏掉的那辆车吗？是的。我终于买了一辆新车。所以有很多次我只是，
my car's not running and I would walk to IHop and I was very thankful for it.
Lady, you know we lived in the same area at first. I lived by an IHop as well.
It's the same IHop. We probably might have been there at the same time. We didn't even know it.
So yeah, when I first moved to L.A., I went to IHop all the time and now I've moved kind of
further away and now I'm at a Denny's.
Well, you guys let us know. Are you Denny's our IHop? I'm very curious.
And you guys, we know some of you might skip this episode when you rewatch.
but we hope you won't skip our breakdown because it's really fun.
我的车不能开了，我会步行去IHOP，我非常感谢它。女士，你知道我们起初住在同一个地区。我也住在一家IHOP旁边。是同一家IHOP。我们可能在同一时间去过那里。我们甚至不知道。所以是的，当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我一直去IHOP，现在我搬得比较远了，现在我在一家丹尼餐厅。好吧，你们让我们知道。你们是丹尼餐厅还是IHOP？我很好奇。而且你们，我们知道你们有些人重看时可能会跳过这一集。但我们希望你们不会跳过我们的拆解，因为它真的很有趣。
We have some great shares about the episode.
And then Sam and I try to explain Lord of the Rings to Jenna.
We don't do that great of a job, but we tried.
Well, it was very funny for me to re-listen to that now that I've seen the movie.
And now I know what you're talking about.
And you don't do such a bad job.
Aw.
Except I say, I say Sauron.
我们有一些关于这一集的很棒的分享。然后山姆和我试着向珍娜解释《指环王》。我们做得不是很好，但我们试过了。好吧，现在我已经看过电影了，再听一遍那个对我来说非常有趣。现在我知道你们在说什么了。而且你们做得并不差。噢。除了我说，我说索伦。
Wrong.
All right, everyone.
Here's your second drink of Prince Family Paper.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
错了。好了，各位。这是你们的第二杯《普林斯家族纸业》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重看播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Hi, Angela.
Hey, Jenna.
How's it going?
It's going good.
Are you ready to destroy a small family business today?
Oh, Prince Family Paper.
每周我们将拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嗨，安吉拉。嘿，珍娜。怎么样？进展顺利。你准备好今天摧毁一家小型家族企业了吗？哦，普林斯家族纸业。
The Prince family.
They're the sweetest family.
Well, we're going to take them down.
I guess we are.
So awful and cringy.
Oh, there's a lot of cringe in this one.
There sure is.
Guys, it's Season 5, Episode 13, Prince Family Paper, written by B.J. Novak and directed by Asad Kalada.
普林斯一家。他们是最可爱的家庭。好吧，我们要把他们搞垮。我想我们是。太糟糕和尴尬了。哦，这一集里有很多尴尬。确实有很多。伙计们，这是第五季第13集，《普林斯家族纸业》，由B.J.诺瓦克编剧，阿萨德·卡拉达导演。
Here's your summary.
Oh.
David Wallace calls Michael Scott on the phone.
It's so funny to me.
I'm so sorry to interrupt your summary that I acted surprised.
That I was going to read a summary.
You're like, here's a summary.
I went, oh.
这是你们的摘要。哦。大卫·华莱士给迈克尔·斯科特打电话。这对我来说太搞笑了。我很抱歉打断了你的摘要，我表现得很惊讶。我要读摘要。你就像，这是摘要。我去了，哦。
Oh.
Oh, well, look whose sassy pants has a summary.
She has one every weekend.
Just expect it.
Okay, go.
David Wallace calls Michael Scott on the phone.
He wants to get his help gathering intel on a rival paper company called Prince Family Paper.
哦。哦。哦，好吧，看看谁的俏皮裤有摘要。她每个周末都有一个。期待它就行了。好吧，开始。大卫·华莱士给迈克尔·斯科特打电话。他想寻求他的帮助，收集关于一家名为普林斯家族纸业的竞争对手纸业公司的情报。
Michael takes Dwight along as his backup.
And meanwhile, the gang debate whether or not Hillary Swank qualifies as hot.
Yep.
All right. I have to say one thing. I just got to get this out. Get it out. There used to be a magazine. I don't know which one. You know who you are. They would do this thing. Who wore it best? Oh, yeah. And they would put two people side by side in like the same dress or skirt or pants. And there was always one person that wore it best. Right? You know? And they would have a percentage like people voted. People voted. And you might have worn it best because you were tall and not five.
one. Okay. Okay. And maybe you knew to wear the right kind of heels and someone else wore
fleck flops with it. I don't know. Right. I'm just saying to that magazine and people that
like to compare who wore it best or who's hot or who's not, I say suck it. Thank you, Angela.
迈克尔带着德怀特作为他的后援。与此同时，大家在争论希拉里·斯万克是否算火辣。是的。是的。好吧，我得说一件事。我只是得把它说出来。说出来。曾经有一本杂志。我不知道是哪一本。你知道你是谁。他们会做这件事。谁穿得最好？哦，是的。他们会把两个人并排放在一起，穿同样的裙子或裤子。总有一个人穿得最好。对吧？你知道吗？他们会有一个百分比，就像人们投票一样。人们投票。你可能穿得最好，因为你很高，而不是五英尺一英寸。好吧。好吧。也许你知道穿什么样的高跟鞋，而别人穿了人字拖。我不知道。对。我只是对那本杂志和喜欢比较谁穿得最好或谁火辣或谁不火辣的人说，去死吧。谢谢，安吉拉。
That's all I'm going to say. Well, that was clearly a general comment. Nothing based on personal
experience, I can tell. I'll have you know I've also been the subject of a who wore it best.
So I feel that. Yeah. Very good. You know what? You all wear it best. We all wear it how we wear it.
Yeah. Okay. That's how I wore it. Period. That's my body. That's how my body wears stuff.
How about who wore it? Me. I wore it. Yeah. A hundred percent to me for wearing it.
And you know what? I got dressed this morning. You're welcome. As you can tell this. This
episode might have triggered something for us. As you can tell, two gals are sitting here,
not super appreciating debates on who's hot or who's not. Yeah. Kevin has a lot of thoughts about it.
这就是我要说的。好吧，那显然是一个普遍的评论。没什么基于个人经验的，我看得出来。我得让你知道，我也曾是“谁穿得最好”的主题。所以我感同身受。是的。非常好。你知道吗？你们都穿得最好。我们都按照我们穿的方式穿。是的。好吧。那就是我穿它的方式。句号。那是我的身体。那是我的身体穿东西的方式。谁穿的怎么样？我。我穿的。是的。百分之百归我，因为我穿了它。而且你知道吗？我今天早上穿好了衣服。不客气。正如你们所看到的。这一集可能触发了我们的一些东西。正如你们所看到的，两个女孩坐在这里，不太欣赏关于谁火辣或谁不火辣的辩论。是的。凯文对此有很多想法。
This might be the most Kevin ever spoke in a whole episode. Yes. I think, is this his most
line count ever? Possibly. Well, I think we should get to some fast facts. I agree. Here we go.
Fast fact number one. New director alert. Yeah. Assad Kalata. Yes. So our line producer, Randy Cordray,
had worked with Assad before, and he told us that Assad was actually originally supposed to direct
an episode in season four. But that season got cut because of the writer's strike. Oh. And so they
slotted him for season five instead. So we could have almost gotten to work with this man earlier.
And I tell you what, he is a delight. You guys, he's like television legend. He's directed everything.
Yes. He has directed 77 episodes of The Facts of Life. And 100.
这可能是凯文在整集中说得最多的一次。是的。我想，这是他有史以来台词最多的一次吗？可能。好吧，我认为我们应该进入一些快速事实。我同意。我们开始吧。快速事实第一号。新导演警报。是的。阿萨德·卡拉达。是的。所以我们的制片主任，兰迪·科德雷，以前和阿萨德合作过，他告诉我们阿萨德实际上最初应该导演第四季的一集。但那一季因为编剧罢工被砍了。哦。所以他们把他安排到了第五季。所以我们差点就能更早和这个人合作了。我告诉你们，他是一个乐子。伙计们，他就像电视传奇。他导演了一切。是的。他导演了77集《生活的事实》。和100。
17 episodes of Who's the Boss?
I know who's the boss.
If your name is Angela, you know who's the boss.
What?
So the female leads characters named Angela.
You guys, this show was out in the 90s.
I was in college in the 90s.
I cannot even tell you how many people left this on my answering machine.
17集《谁是老板？》我知道《谁是老板》。如果你的名字是安吉拉，你就知道《谁是老板》。什么？所以女性主角的名字叫安吉拉。伙计们，这个节目在90年代就播出了。我在90年代上大学。我甚至无法告诉你们有多少人在我的答录机上留下了这个。
Angela?
I had that on my voicemail.
I would say on a monthly basis.
That's crazy.
Let me finish telling you a little.
little bit about Assad. We loved working with him. I found an interview he did where he said this,
which I thought was so great. He said that the most essential thing for making a successful comedy
is casting. He said that is because, quote, you cannot make the actor be funny. Comedy is all about
安吉拉？我的语音信箱里有那个。我可以说每个月都有。那太疯狂了。让我说完关于阿萨德的一点点。我们喜欢和他一起工作。我发现了他做的一次采访，他说，我觉得这太棒了。他说制作一部成功喜剧最本质的事情是选角。他说这是因为，引用，你不能让演员变得有趣。喜剧全是关于
rhythm, timing, pace, and energy. I agree. I thought that was so well said. Yeah. All right, fast fact number two.
We got a lot of fan questions about the hot or not storyline.
This one comes from Joe S.
Who asked, what inspired the subplot of the debate about whether or not Hillary Swank was hot or not?
Was it a magazine that said who wore it best?
It wasn't.
B.J. Novak did an interview with Indy Week, and he said that he was on a flight,
节奏、时机、步调和能量。我同意。我觉得那说得太好了。是的。好吧，快速事实第二号。我们收到了很多关于“火辣还是不火辣”故事情节的粉丝问题。这个来自乔·S。他问，关于希拉里·斯万克是否火辣的辩论的子情节是什么灵感？是那本说“谁穿得最好”的杂志吗？不是。不是。B.J.诺瓦克接受了Indy Week的采访，他说他在飞机上，
and two of the in-flight movies were P.S. I Love You and the Great Debaters.
They were both Hillary Swank movies.
He was tasked with coming up with a B plot for an episode and he thought, quote, why not debate about Hillary Swank?
And then he decided that the characters could debate whether or not she is attractive.
We got more questions from Amy J. and Rohit R.
How does Hillary Swank feel about this episode?
Oh, wow.
Good question.
两部机上电影是《附注：我爱你》和《激辩风云》。它们都是希拉里·斯万克的电影。他的任务是为一集构思一个B情节，他想，引用，为什么不辩论希拉里·斯万克呢？然后他决定角色们可以辩论她是否有吸引力。我们收到了更多来自艾米·J和罗希特·R的问题。希拉里·斯万克对这一集感觉如何？哦，哇。好问题。
Very good question.
Well, she did an interview with Time magazine shortly after this episode came out.
She was asked if she had seen the episode, and she said this.
I'm not a big television watcher, but definitely everyone made me aware of it.
Oh, geez.
I think it's flattering anytime someone mentions you, but I don't think of myself in terms of that,
meaning like she doesn't lead with if she's hot or not.
Right.
非常好的问题。好吧，在这一集播出后不久，她接受了《时代》杂志的采访。她被问到是否看过这一集，她说，我不是一个电视迷，但肯定每个人都让我知道了它。哦，天哪。我觉得任何时候有人提到你都是一种恭维，但我不从那个角度考虑自己，意思是她不以自己是否火辣来领先。对。
Later on in the interview, she was asked about women in Hollywood in general, and she replied,
There is so much put on the way we look, which is interesting.
going back to your office question,
are you hot or are you not?
It really does a disservice
because there's so much more to life
than looking a certain way.
We love you, Hillary.
在采访的后期，她被问到关于好莱坞女性的总体情况，她回答说，我们看起来的方式被赋予了太多东西，这很有趣。回到你们的办公室问题，你火辣还是不火辣？这真的帮了倒忙，因为生活中还有比看起来某种样子更重要的事情。我们爱你，希拉里。
Hillary, well said.
Well said.
Fast fact number three,
Hillary Swank is a badass.
Would you like to hear a little about her?
Yes.
All right.
She was born in Lincoln, Nebraska.
希拉里，说得好。说得好。快速事实第三号，希拉里·斯万克是个狠角色。你想听听关于她的一点点吗？是的。好吧。她出生在内布拉斯加州的林肯。
She competed in the Junior Olympics
and the Washington
state championships in swimming, and she ranked fifth in state in all-around gymnastics.
Wow.
All-around gymnastics.
That's the one where you have to do all the things.
You do all the things.
She ranked fifth in the state.
她参加了青少年奥运会和华盛顿州游泳锦标赛，她在全能体操方面排名州第五。哇。全能体操。那是你必须做所有事情的那一个。你做所有的事情。她在州里排名第五。
Okay.
Her parents separated when she was a teenager, and she really wanted to be an actress, so her
mom moved with her to Los Angeles when she was 16 years old.
And she's spoken a lot about this.
They did not have a lot of money for a while, and they lived out of their car.
They did eventually find a place to live.
She enrolled in school.
And then when she was 20, so four years after she moved to L.A., she landed the starring role in the next karate kid.
好吧。她的父母在她十几岁时分开了，她真的很想成为一名演员，所以她妈妈在她16岁时和她一起搬到了洛杉矶。她谈了很多关于这一点。他们有一段时间没有多少钱，他们住在车里。他们最终确实找到了住的地方。她入学了。然后当她20岁时，也就是她搬到洛杉矶四年后，她获得了《新小子难缠》的主演角色。
Julie Pierce.
Yeah.
You know all about this, Ange.
I do because, you guys, I got really into Cobra Kai this past year.
Are you guys watching Cobra Kai?
It's so good.
I'm not watching it.
朱莉·皮尔斯。是的。是的。你对这个很了解，安吉。我知道，因为，伙计们，我去年真的很迷《眼镜蛇道馆》。你们在看《眼镜蛇道馆》吗？太棒了。我没看。
Should I be watching it?
I am loving it.
It's also just major, like, 80s, 90s.
nostalgia. It's so good. Is this something I can watch with my kids? Or is it more adulty? I've heard it's a little bit skews older.
It's skews older. Than my kids. Yes. I'm not watching it with my kids. Oh, this is your time. Yeah. Okay. Josh and I watch it together. I'm sure there's, you know, teenagers that watch it. But Josh and I watch it together. So basically, it's sort of picking up where they are now, right? Mm-hmm. With the two lead guys. And John Hurwitz, who's the co-creator, they reached out to me to play one of the kids.
mom. What? Yes, and I wanted to do it, but it was filming in Atlanta, and you basically have to go to
Atlanta for a while, and I couldn't do that. I couldn't be away from my kids for that long. Yeah,
you know, it wasn't like an in and out. But listen, John Hurwitz, if you ever moved to Los Angeles,
我应该看吗？我很喜欢它。它也只是主要的，就像80年代，90年代。怀旧。太棒了。这是我可以和孩子们一起看的东西吗？还是更成人化？我听说它有点偏向年长。它偏向年长。比我的孩子。是的。我没有和我的孩子们一起看。哦，这是你的时间。是的。好吧。乔什和我一起看。我相信有，你知道，青少年看它。但乔什和我一起看。所以基本上，它有点像从他们现在所在的地方开始，对吧？嗯。有两个男主角。而约翰·赫维茨，他是联合创作者，他们联系我扮演其中一个孩子的妈妈。什么？是的，我想做，但它在亚特兰大拍摄，你基本上必须去亚特兰大一段时间，我做不到。我不能离开我的孩子们那么久。是的，你知道，那不是那种进进出出。但听着，约翰·赫维茨，如果你曾经搬到洛杉矶，
if you ever decide to film here, I am there. People have been speculating, will Julie come back?
Because they're bringing all the characters back. And this is what John Hurwitz said in an interview.
They discussed the possibility of bringing Julie Pierce on the show.
He said, in our writer's room, we speak about literally every character that has appeared in the Miyagi verse.
They call it the Miyagi verse.
So it's obvious we've spoken about Julie Pierce.
As to whether or not she'll return to the series, that's something you'll just have to wait to find out.
I'm here for it, John.
如果你曾经决定在这里拍摄，我就在那里。人们一直在猜测，朱莉会回来吗？因为他们正在把所有角色带回来。这就是约翰·赫维茨在采访中所说的。他们讨论了把朱莉·皮尔斯带回节目的可能性。他说，在我们的编剧室里，我们谈论了字面上每一个出现在宫城宇宙中的角色。他们称之为宫城宇宙。所以很明显我们谈论过朱莉·皮尔斯。至于她是否会回到系列中，那是你只需要等待才能发现的事情。我支持它，约翰。
Bring her back.
Also, a little bit of office crossover, Jen Salada has directed several episodes of Cobra Kai.
Wow.
Yeah.
I would love it if Hillary's like, Hillary, go back.
Go do a guest star on Cobra Kai.
It'd be so good.
And then maybe there's like some little bit you could do in her episode.
带她回来。此外，一点点《办公室》交叉，简·萨拉达导演了几集《眼镜蛇道馆》。哇。是的。如果希拉里像，希拉里，回去。去《眼镜蛇道馆》客串一下，我会很高兴的。那会很好。然后也许你可以做一点点你在她那一集里能做的事情。
Yes, Hillary, maybe I could be your best friend.
This is it.
And then I could go just for a week, John, just like four days.
Yeah.
Okay.
There, we worked it out.
Gin Salada.
Genslotta drinks it.
是的，希拉里，也许我可以成为你最好的朋友。就是这样。然后我可以只去一周，约翰，就像四天。是的。好吧。在那里，我们解决了。简·萨拉达。简·萨拉达喝了它。
Make it happen.
Well, Hillary Sank was 20 years old when she was a next karate kid,
when she was 25 years old, she did the lead role in Boys Don't Cry.
Wow.
And she won an Oscar.
She is one of the youngest women to ever win an Oscar.
She also won an Oscar for her lead role in Million Dollar Baby.
That movie destroyed me.
让它发生。好吧，希拉里·斯万克在《新小子难缠》时20岁，当她25岁时，她在《男孩别哭》中担任主角。哇。她赢得了奥斯卡。她是赢得奥斯卡的最年轻的女性之一。她还因在《百万美元宝贝》中的主角角色赢得了奥斯卡。那部电影摧毁了我。
I mean, both of those movies.
I mean, they're, ugh.
There are only 12 other actresses who have won two or more lead actress Oscars.
Those are both lead actress Oscars.
So she's in a very impressive club there.
She sure is.
So that's Hillary Swank, y'all.
Well, Hillary, we are here for you.
我的意思是，那两部电影。我的意思是，它们，呃。只有12位其他女演员赢得了两项或更多最佳女主角奥斯卡奖。那两项都是最佳女主角奥斯卡奖。所以她在那个非常令人印象深刻的俱乐部里。她确实是。所以这就是希拉里·斯万克，你们。好吧，希拉里，我们在这里支持你。
We should take a break and we come back.
There is a classic Jim Prank.
This episode opens with everyone just working at their desks.
We're just working.
Just a normal day.
No biggie.
But then Dwight discovers a red wire that's plugged into his computer.
No other computers have red wires.
我们应该休息一下，回来时。有一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。这一集以每个人都在办公桌前工作开始。我们只是在工作。只是正常的一天。没什么大不了的。但随后德怀特发现一根红线插在他的电脑里。没有其他电脑有红线。
What is it?
Yeah, it's a new wire.
It's never been there before.
Yeah.
Well, he starts tearing at this wire.
Yeah, he wants to know where it's coming from.
Yeah.
In the script, it says Dwight pulls the wire off the floor and follows it to the wall.
那是什么？是的，这是一根新线。以前从来没有过。是的。好吧，他开始扯这根线。是的，他想知道它从哪里来。是的。在剧本里，它说德怀特把线从地板上拉起来，跟着它走到墙边。
It goes over a doorframe under Phyllis's desk and Dwight crawls under Phyllis's desk.
Oh, we did it a little differently.
We did it a little differently.
First of all, you can't crawl through Phyllis's desk because there was like a backstop, right?
Yeah.
So it doesn't go all the way through to Stanley's desk.
And in the script, Phyllis says, Dwight, get out of there.
And that's pretty much in the episode.
它越过门框，在菲利斯的桌子下面，德怀特爬到菲利斯的桌子下面。哦，我们做得有点不同。我们做得有点不同。首先，你不能爬过菲利斯的桌子，因为有一个挡板，对吧？是的。所以它没有一直通到斯坦利的桌子。在剧本里，菲利斯说，德怀特，从那里出来。这在剧集中基本就是这样。
And then Dwight would have said, shush, shush, shush.
But I think rain improvised, shut up, Phyllis.
So Dwight's going to follow this wire into the hall.
Yeah, all the way outside and up a telephone pole, which we can see over Jim's shoulder in Jim's talking head.
Right.
And it is a real telephone pole.
It's a real telephone pole.
Jim says he got 500 feet of red wire at a flea.
然后德怀特会说，嘘，嘘，嘘。但我认为雷恩即兴发挥了，闭嘴，菲利斯。所以德怀特要跟着这根线走到大厅。是的，一直到外面，爬上一根电话杆，我们在吉姆的谈话头中可以看到它在吉姆的肩膀上。对。那是一根真正的电话杆。那是一根真正的电话杆。吉姆说他在跳蚤市场以20美元买了500英尺的红线。
market for 20 bucks. How long did this take him? Jim has a lot of extra time. He gets to work so
early. Pam is like, you know what, I know we were going to carpool, but you've got that Dwight
prank and you've got to go at three in the morning and I'm going to sleep in. Yeah. Like, what's the
real life side of that? I reached out to Randy to find out how we did this stunt of rain up on this
telephone pole. Right. He can't climb a real telephone pole. That's not safe. No.
Because what he told me was that the pole over Jim's shoulder really is an actual working utility pole that's embedded in our sidewalk, you know, right out there.
Folks, don't go climb it for a photo.
Don't climb it.
这花了他多长时间？吉姆有很多额外的时间。他上班很早。帕姆就像，你知道吗，我知道我们要拼车，但你有那个德怀特恶作剧，你得在凌晨三点去，我要睡懒觉。是的。就像，那现实生活的一面是什么？我联系了兰迪，想找出我们是如何做这个雷恩爬上电话杆的特技的。对。他不能爬真正的电话杆。那不安全。不。因为他告诉我的事是，吉姆肩膀上的杆子确实是一根实际工作的公用事业杆，嵌入在我们的人行道里，你知道，就在那里。伙计们，不要去爬它拍照。不要爬它。
You can get electrocuted.
Yeah, it carried high voltage electricity.
They couldn't even have a stunt person dressed as Dwight climb that pole.
Yeah.
So our production designer Michael Gallenberg and his construction team rented a matching utility pole.
You can do that, I guess.
Oh.
Where is that?
你可能会触电。是的，它带有高压电。他们甚至不能让一个穿着德怀特衣服的特技演员爬那根杆子。是的。所以我们的制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格和他的施工团队租了一根匹配的公用事业杆。你可以那样做，我想。哦。那在哪里？
I mean, seriously, how do they know these things?
This is the crazy part of Hollywood magic.
Oh, you know what I'm going to do today?
I'm going to rent a faky telephone pole.
Yeah.
That's huge.
Huge.
Well, they put it up in our parking lot between the two sound stages,
我的意思是，认真地，他们怎么知道这些事情？这是好莱坞魔法疯狂的一部分。哦，你知道我今天要做什么吗？我要租一根假的电话杆。是的。那太大了。巨大。好吧，他们把它放在我们两个摄影棚之间的停车场里，
and they put like a green padded platform around it.
In case you fell?
Yep.
And they put up a big green screen behind the whole floor.
thing, and then they brought rain out, along with like a stunt coordinator and a safety officer,
and they had rain climb up. It was only a few feet that he had to climb. And then in post-production,
they had their visual effects team digitally add rain to the real pole over Jim's shoulder.
They superimposed like one pole onto the other. Yes. Got it. Even though rain was really only
他们在它周围放了一个绿色软垫平台。以防你摔倒？是的。他们在整个地板后面放了一个大绿屏。东西，然后他们把雷恩带出来，连同一个特技协调员和一个安全官员，他们让雷恩爬上去。他只需要爬几英尺。然后在后期制作中，他们让他们的视觉特效团队在吉姆肩膀上的真实杆子上数字添加雷恩。他们把一根杆子叠加在另一根上。是的。明白了。即使雷恩实际上只是
a little bit off the ground, they could like hike it up so it looked like he was like half
way up the pole. Yeah. That's movie magic, folks. That is some good movie magic. But here's the thing that gets me about that. That's like real special effects kind of like stunted stuff for our little TV show about a paper company. Like I never really thought hard about how much work it took to do that gag until we went to break it down. Right? Like it's such a quick little blip and you're like, that was like two weeks of figuring that out.
Prep. Yeah. I feel like every week we are learning how much Michael Gallenberg, Kyle Alexander, Phil Shea, our wardrobe department, set designers, how they all made these little moments happen and made it seamless.
Yeah. I know. So much work goes into these little things. It's amazing. The fruit fly wrangler. We had to know their like mating cycle.
Craziness. It's crazy. Well, that was the cold open. Now we start this episode. Michael's in his office. He's on the phone with David Wallace.
I feel like David's really playing Michael here because he dangles out that regional supervisor job.
He's like, you know, I still haven't filled that slot yet.
And Michael's like, oh.
离地面一点点，他们可以把它调高，看起来他就像爬到杆子的一半。是的。那是电影魔法，伙计们。那是一些好的电影魔法。但这就是关于那个让我困惑的事情。那就像为我们关于纸业公司的小电视节目做的真正的特效特技东西。我从来没有真正认真想过做那个恶作剧需要多少工作，直到我们去拆解它。对吧？就像它是一个如此快速的小闪烁，你就像，那是两周的摸索。准备。是的。我觉得每周我们都在学习迈克尔·加伦伯格、凯尔·亚历山大、菲尔·谢、我们的服装部门、布景设计师，他们是如何让这些小瞬间发生并使之无缝衔接的。是的。我知道。这么多工作投入到这些小事情中。太神奇了。果蝇驯兽师。我们必须知道它们的交配周期。疯狂。太疯狂了。好吧，那是冷开场。现在我们开始这一集。迈克尔在他的办公室里。他正在和大卫·华莱士通电话。我觉得大卫真的在玩弄迈克尔，因为他悬挂着那个区域主管的工作。他就像，你知道，我还没有填补那个空缺。迈克尔就像，哦。
And then he asked Michael to go do this thing.
Yeah, to go spy on this tiny little paper company.
I know.
To do some field work.
Michael's so excited.
Oh, yeah.
During this scene, I was really struck by the toys on Michael's desk because they would rotate them.
They would, you guys.
然后他让迈克尔去做这件事。是的，去监视这家微小的纸业公司。我知道。去做一些实地工作。迈克尔太兴奋了。哦，是的。在这一幕中，我真的被迈克尔桌子上的玩具打动了，因为他们会轮换它们。他们会，伙计们。
Every once in while, there would be some new toys.
Boys. Here's what was on his desk. A Rubik's Cube, not finished. A tiny pool table. Yes. A colorful plastic expanding ball thingy. You know that thingy? Yeah, yeah. That's a staple. Yes, and also the wind-up teeth. Those are always there. But the pool table had moved. So he's clearly played it recently. And it's on top of all the stuff in his inbox. He can't get to anything in his inbox. It's not important. The pool table is number one of things to do.
Yeah.
It made me laugh.
A miniature pool table in his inbox says everything you need to know about Michael Scott's work ethic.
That's right.
Stanley and Phyllis are going to start having this conversation about whether or not they think Hillary Swank is hot.
And the rest of the gang gets involved.
每隔一段时间，就会有一些新玩具。男孩。这是他桌子上的东西。一个魔方，没完成。一个小台球桌。是的。一个多彩的塑料膨胀球东西。你知道那个东西吗？是的，是的。那是主食。是的，还有发条牙齿。那些总是在那里。但台球桌移动了。所以他显然最近玩过它。而且它在收件箱里所有东西的上面。他无法触及收件箱里的任何东西。那不重要。台球桌是待办事项的第一位。是的。它让我笑了。收件箱里的微型台球桌说明了你需要知道关于迈克尔·斯科特职业道德的一切。那是对的。斯坦利和菲利斯要开始讨论他们是否认为希拉里·斯万克火辣。其余的人也参与进来。
I feel like these kind of moments happen in small offices.
You sort of start to debate things.
Like you pick a soccer team during the playoffs and people debate about the players and it can become a whole thing.
And it's just a way to fill.
the boredom. Oh, for sure. I have a bone to pick with Jim. Why is that? At three minutes, 18 seconds,
I titled this moment, what the hell, Jim? What is the moment? Jim suggests they put it to a vote in the
bullpen. Angela says she isn't voting, and Jim says, nobody cares. Oh. What the hell, Jim? That's some
Jim sass. Mm-hmm. Jim sass. Did you notice what Pam said? What did Pam say? Pam says, did you see her with her bangs?
我觉得这种时刻发生在小办公室里。你开始辩论事情。就像你在季后赛期间挑选一支足球队，人们辩论球员，它可以变成一整件事。这只是填补无聊的一种方式。哦，当然。我对吉姆有意见。为什么？在三分钟18秒，我把这一刻命名为，搞什么鬼，吉姆？那一刻是什么？吉姆建议他们在牛棚里投票。安吉拉说她不投票，吉姆说，没人关心。哦。搞什么鬼，吉姆？那是吉姆的傲慢。嗯。吉姆的傲慢。你注意到帕姆说了什么吗？帕姆说了什么？帕姆说，你看到她留刘海了吗？
And lady, this made me laugh out loud because I have just recently gotten bangs.
And people have a lot of opinions about it.
They do have opinions about my bangs.
But what made me laugh was that before I got my bangs, I, of course, Googled images of people with bangs.
You have to do research.
You don't just, you got to look at all the pictures.
You Googled people with bangs.
You texted me, I think I'm going to get bangs.
女士，这让我大声笑了出来，因为我最近刚留了刘海。人们对它有很多意见。他们确实对我的刘海有意见。但让我笑的是，在我留刘海之前，我当然谷歌了留刘海的人的图片。你必须做研究。你不能只是，你得看所有的照片。你谷歌了留刘海的人。你给我发短信，我想我要留刘海了。
Yeah.
To which I replied, oh, no.
I said, I think I'm going to get bangs right now because I was getting a haircut in the moment.
By the time you replied, it was done.
I know.
I was like, oh, I was busy with the kids.
I decided we were going to paint.
I bought the canvas and all the paint stuff.
是的。对此我回答，哦，不。我说，我想我现在要留刘海了，因为我当时正在剪头发。当你回复时，它已经完成了。我知道。我当时想，哦，我正忙着孩子们。我决定我们要画画。我买了画布和所有的颜料东西。
We're outside.
We'd made this huge mess.
I'd set my phone aside so I didn't get paint on it.
And then I just thought I'd check in, see what's happening.
And I see this text from you that's half an hour old that says, I think I'm going to get bangs now.
And I was like, oh, no, I didn't get to weigh in.
But lady, I think they're adorable. I think they're super cute because they're curly.
I'm loving it. I bring it up because one of the people I saw in my research was Hillary Swank with bangs.
我们在外面。我们弄得一团糟。我把手机放在一边，这样我就不会弄上颜料。然后我只是想看看，看看发生了什么。我看到你发来的一条半小时前的短信，说，我想我现在要留刘海了。我当时想，哦，不，我没能发表意见。但女士，我觉得它们很可爱。我觉得它们超级可爱，因为它们是卷曲的。我很喜欢。我提出来是因为我在研究中看到的人之一是留刘海的希拉里·斯万克。
So when Pam said this in the scene, it made me laugh. But I really based my bangs on some like Mia Farrow from Hannah and her sisters.
You look very 70s, kind of like beachy wave with bangs.
A little bit of Terry Gar.
Terry Gar wore some bangs like no one's business.
That's right.
main inspiration was probably Stevie Nix. And I will admit that after getting my bangs, I did
style my hair in a full Stevie Nix. And then I took pictures and I put them side by side. I was too shy to
post. But I want to see the side by side. You want to see my Stevie Nix picture. Oh my God. Do you have it
所以当帕姆在这一幕中说这个时，它让我笑了。但我真的把我的刘海基于米娅·法罗在《汉娜姐妹》中的样子。你看起来很70年代，有点像海滩波浪配刘海。一点点特里·加尔。特里·加尔留了一些刘海，没人能比。那是对的。主要灵感可能来自史蒂薇·尼克斯。而且我承认，在留了刘海后，我确实把我的头发做成了完整的史蒂薇·尼克斯风格。然后我拍了照片，把它们放在一起对比。我太害羞了，不敢发。但我想要看对比。你想看我的史蒂薇·尼克斯照片。天哪。你有它
on your phone? Yeah. I mean, I really did this. Oh, my God. Jilla, this is amazing.
Oh, you kind of did the same mouth. I tried it. I put on the same necklace. I did like a whole thing.
Oh, you did. We got to put that in Office Ladies' Pod Stories, please.
It's okay. I mean, I'm doing a whole pouty mouth, so I got a little bit, like, shy.
You even did the dark eyeliner. I did, I'm telling you, she was my inspo.
This was a whole afternoon. I thought I knew your life. This was a whole day. I didn't know what was happening.
I mean, I had to take off my glasses for the picture. I know. Which actually made it a little hard to take the picture.
Honey, I couldn't see their... Tell me about it. I can't tell you how many photos I've taken of Josh and the kids.
在你的手机上吗？是的。我的意思是，我真的做了这个。天哪。吉拉，这太棒了。哦，你做了同样的嘴。我试过了。我戴上了同样的项链。我做了一整套东西。哦，你做了。我们必须把它放进《办公室》女士播客故事里，拜托。没关系。我的意思是，我做了一个嘟嘴，所以我有点，有点害羞。你甚至画了深色眼线。我做了，我告诉你，她是我的灵感。这是一个下午。我以为我了解你的生活。这是整整一天。我不知道发生了什么。我的意思是，我不得不摘下眼镜拍照。我知道。这实际上让拍照有点困难。亲爱的，我看不见他们的……别提了。我无法告诉你们我拍了多少乔什和孩子们的照片。
Because, you know, when you're like a family, one parent has to take the picture.
Yeah.
And half the time I don't have my glasses because I'm not good about wearing them.
And Josh will be like, babe, these are out of focus.
I'm like, I can't tell.
I just click.
I love how we literally could not be more off topic right now.
We are so off topic.
因为，你知道，当你像一家人一样时，总得有一个家长来拍照。是的。而且有一半时间我没戴眼镜，因为我不习惯戴。乔什就会说，宝贝，这些照片失焦了。我说，我看不出来。我只管按快门。我喜欢我们现在完全偏离主题的样子。我们太偏离主题了。
Okay.
All right.
We'll get back to it.
Let's get back on topic.
All right, all right, all right.
So we are now, oh, God.
You guys, we're about to talk about a scene I absolutely loved.
It's a driving scene between Dwight and Michael.
好吧。行。我们回到正题吧。让我们回到主题。好，好，好。所以我们现在，哦，天哪。伙计们，我们要谈论一个我非常喜欢的场景。那是德怀特和迈克尔之间的一场开车戏。
They're headed to Prince Family Paper.
Did you notice how much they bicker in this scene? They're like an old married couple.
I loved it. They bicker about who would seduce the fictional daughter. They don't even know if this person exists.
Yeah. And they bicker about Denny's and IHop. They bicker about the clouds. Dwight says, get your clouds right. Michael tells them to shut up.
But I have a background catch. What is it? Oh, it sent me down a Google path, Jenna.
All right. So whenever we have driving scenes, we always look for palm trees, right? Yeah. Spot the palm tree. And this one, I recognize the street they were on. It's Chandler Boulevard. It's a residential street. And guess what else I recognized? What? It was trash day. And there were blue recycle bins in every driveway. I took a few photos. Okay. I'll put those in pod. So then I thought, is that what the recycled trash bins look like in Scranton?
So that took me to the recycling laws for La Cawanna County.
Oh.
他们正前往普林斯家族纸业公司。你注意到他们在这一幕里吵得有多厉害了吗？他们就像一对老夫老妻。我太喜欢了。他们争论谁会去诱惑那个虚构的女儿。他们甚至不知道这个人是否存在。是的。他们还争论丹尼餐厅和国际煎饼屋（IHOP）。他们争论云彩。德怀特说，把你的云彩弄对。迈克尔让他闭嘴。但我有一个背景发现。是什么？哦，它让我走上了一条谷歌搜索之路，珍娜。好吧。所以每当我们有开车戏时，我们总是寻找棕榈树，对吧？是的。寻找棕榈树。而这一次，我认出了他们所在的街道。那是钱德勒大道。那是一条住宅区街道。你猜我还认出了什么？什么？那是垃圾回收日。每个车道上都有蓝色的回收箱。我拍了几张照片。好的。我会把它们放在播客里。然后我想，斯克兰顿的回收垃圾箱长那样吗？于是我查了拉克瓦纳县的回收法律。哦。
Hang with me because there's a woman named Barbara, who I am now fascinated by.
First of all, that is not what recycle bins look like in La Cawana County.
So there's are like these blue round tubs.
Okay.
Unless they've changed, you guys can correct me.
Ours are these like skinny rectangles with lids.
Yep.
So here's an article I read from April of 2019.
听我说，因为有一个叫芭芭拉的女人，我现在对她很着迷。首先，拉克瓦纳县的回收箱根本不是那样子的。他们的是那种蓝色的圆桶。好吧。除非他们换了，你们可以纠正我。我们的是那种带盖子的细长矩形桶。是的。这是我读到的一篇2019年4月的文章。
Barbara Giovanni is the recycling.
coordinator for La Cawanna County. Barbara shared that the recycling center in La Cawanna County accepts
plastics and glass bottles and jars, aluminum still cans, as well as newspaper. It is a dual-streamed
system. They have containers, bottles, jars, and cans in one, and paper fibers separately. They do not
accept plastic bags, take-out containers, or pizza boxes. And apparently, lady, the recycle centers
get all kinds of wacky things. People put all kinds of crazy things in the recycle bins.
Barbara has a tip for you. She wants you to know. She says there's an easy way to remind yourself what can and cannot be recycled at the La Cawanna County Recycling Center.
Quote, ask yourself, is it a bottle? Is it a jar? If the answer is no, that means it has to be thrown away.
芭芭拉·乔瓦尼是拉克瓦纳县的回收协调员。芭芭拉分享说，拉克瓦纳县的回收中心接受塑料、玻璃瓶和罐子、铝制钢罐以及报纸。这是一个双流系统。他们把容器、瓶子、罐子和罐头放在一个桶里，把纸纤维分开。他们不接受塑料袋、外卖盒或披萨盒。显然，女士，回收中心会收到各种各样的古怪东西。人们把各种疯狂的东西放进回收箱。芭芭拉有一个给你的小贴士。她想让你知道。她说有一个简单的方法可以提醒自己拉克瓦纳县回收中心能回收什么，不能回收什么。引用她的话，“问问自己，它是瓶子吗？它是罐子吗？如果答案是否定的，那就意味着它必须被扔掉。”
I want to meet Barbara. I want to meet Barbara. I want to meet Barbara. It's real simple. Ask yourself. Is this a jar? Is this a bottle? No.
trash.
Wow.
Mm-hmm.
We have to meet her.
Anyway, this was a random thing I noticed in the background.
No palm tree siding.
我想见芭芭拉。我想见芭芭拉。我想见芭芭拉。这很简单。问问自己。这是罐子吗？这是瓶子吗？不是。垃圾。哇。嗯哼。我们必须见她。我们必须见她。总之，这是我在背景中注意到的一个随机事物。没有棕榈树。
Several recycle bins.
Also in the scene, for those of you guys keeping track of how many times Michael Scarn is mentioned in the series, this is one of them, because it's going to be Michael's alias.
And then they get into a real heated argument.
I mean, that has history about Denny's and IHop.
Yeah.
They're going to rendezvous after they get the info.
So Michael says at IHOP.
And Dwight's like, I did not agree to IHop.
几个回收箱。同样在这一幕中，对于那些追踪迈克尔·斯卡恩在系列中被提到多少次的人来说，这是其中之一，因为这将是迈克尔的化名。然后他们陷入了一场真正的激烈争论。我的意思是，关于丹尼餐厅和国际煎饼屋的历史。是的。他们拿到信息后要去会合。所以迈克尔说在国际煎饼屋。德怀特说，我没同意去国际煎饼屋。
Socialist, he says.
He's like, you socialist, I'm going to Denny's.
And Michael's like, you were going to IHop and you will have pancakes and you will like it.
What do you like?
Do you have strong feelings about IHOP or Denny's?
I really don't.
But I would say I've had IHop more because there was one right on campus when I went to
to college, basically like across the street.
社会主义者，他说。他说，你这个社会主义者，我要去丹尼餐厅。迈克尔说，你要去国际煎饼屋，你要吃煎饼，而且你会喜欢的。你喜欢什么？你对国际煎饼屋或丹尼餐厅有强烈的感情吗？我真的没有。但我会说我吃国际煎饼屋更多，因为我上大学时，它基本上就在校园对面。
And we would walk over there.
And there's also one by my kid's pediatrician office.
So I've just been to IHop.
more. I would say that if I'm looking for a pancake, IHOP is going to come to mind. Yeah. But I want to
say these words to you. Oh, what? Moons over my hammy. Oh, is that? That's a Denny special.
And it's real good. Okay. So if I'm wanting more of an egg sandwich, I'm going to have to
head to Denny's. Now I'm just craving breakfast. I know. Me too, Kina. Well, these guys do
eventually get to their destination of Prince family paper.
我们会走过去。我孩子儿科医生办公室旁边也有一家。所以我去国际煎饼屋更多。我会说如果我想吃煎饼，我会想到国际煎饼屋。是的。但我得对你说这些话。哦，什么？“Moons over my hammy”（丹尼餐厅的一款三明治）。哦，那是？那是丹尼餐厅的特色菜。而且非常好吃。好吧。所以如果我想吃鸡蛋三明治，我就得去丹尼餐厅。现在我只想吃早餐。我知道。我也是，基娜。好吧，这些人最终到达了他们的目的地普林斯家族纸业公司。
It's in like a little strip mall.
Right.
And I got a location alert.
Let's do it.
We rented an empty mini mall near the corner of Laurel Canyon and Victory Boulevard in North
Hollywood, California.
We rented a whole mini mall?
I guess we did because Randy said our location manager, Kyle Alexander, had to find a location
它在一个小购物中心里。对。我有一个地点警报。我们来吧。我们在加利福尼亚州北好莱坞的月桂峡谷和胜利大道拐角处租了一个空迷你商场。我们租了整个迷你商场？我想是的，因为兰迪说我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大必须找到一个地点
where we could have some sort of office front that had all windows because we assumed that
if they were going undercover, they couldn't bring a documentary crew with them.
Oh, that's so smart. I didn't even think about that. When I watched, every single shot is through the glass.
Yes. And so they had to be able to have a total glass front on this office. But then we also needed this giant parking lot.
So he was able to find all of that in this little empty mini mall.
I want Kyle to come on the show. Me too. He's like the master of every amazing location.
So good. Get this. We had to bring all those cars. And did you notice the faky snow residue? We put faky snow residue on all the cars. They're still dirty from last week. I know. And then our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, had to create the entire Prince Family Paper offices from scratch. Michael, we want you one too. Michael and Kyle, we want you on. We're coming for you. So they're in the car and Dwight's got a little pair of binoculars and they're coming up with their plan.
Dwight's binoculars are like industrial looking.
我们可以有一个某种办公室门面，全是窗户，因为我们假设如果他们要卧底，他们不能带纪录片摄制组进去。哦，太聪明了。我都没想过。当我观看时，每一个镜头都是透过玻璃拍摄的。是的。所以他们必须在这个办公室有一个全玻璃的门面。但我们也需要这个巨大的停车场。所以他能够在这个小小的空迷你商场里找到所有这些。我想让凯尔上节目。我也是。他就像每个惊人地点的策划大师。太棒了。听着。我们必须带上所有那些车。你注意到那些假雪残留物了吗？我们在所有的车上都放了假雪残留物。它们从上周开始就一直很脏。我知道。然后我们的美术指导迈克尔·加伦伯格必须从零开始创造整个普林斯家族纸业办公室。迈克尔，我们也想让你来。迈克尔和凯尔，我们想让你们来。我们来找你们了。所以他们在车里，德怀特拿着一副小双筒望远镜，他们正在制定计划。德怀特的双筒望远镜看起来很工业化。
They look like they have night vision.
Yeah.
And then here is my question.
Through this whole scene, they are eating.
What are they eating?
Is it a giant can of nuts?
I tried to zoom in.
What is it?
它们看起来像是有夜视功能。是的。然后这是我的问题。在整个场景中，他们都在吃东西。他们在吃什么？是一大罐坚果吗？我试着放大。那是什么？
Did you see it?
I did.
I did take a picture.
I actually loved the blooper for this scene so much that I filmed the blooper and I sent it to rain and texted him.
And I was like, what are you guys eating?
and he was cracking up.
He said, and I am pretty sure those were smoked almonds.
Yeah, they looked like almonds, but they had like stuff on them.
你看到了吗？我看到了。我确实拍了一张照片。我其实非常喜欢这一幕的NG镜头，所以我拍下了NG镜头，发给了雷恩并给他发了短信。我说，你们在吃什么？他笑得前仰后合。他说，我很确定那是烟熏杏仁。是的，它们看起来像杏仁，但上面有东西。
Yeah.
He said he was pretty sure they were smoked almonds.
And while they're eating these almonds, they decide on a signal that they need to give each other if there's danger.
They need to get out of there.
And Dwight says, you've got to lick your lips.
And Michael does a quick lick.
Meanwhile, they're eating these almonds the whole time.
And Dwight goes, no, like this.
是的。他说他很确定那是烟熏杏仁。当他们吃这些杏仁时，他们决定了一个信号，如果遇到危险，他们需要给对方发信号。他们需要离开那里。德怀特说，你得舔舔嘴唇。迈克尔快速舔了一下。与此同时，他们一直在吃这些杏仁。德怀特说，不，像这样。
and does this big like,
like, ah,
the thing?
Yeah.
And in the process of doing this,
they started laughing,
and when they did,
rain in his laughter,
然后做了这个大大的，像，啊，那个动作？是的。在这个过程中，他们开始大笑，当他们笑的时候，雷恩在笑声中，
in his goofaw,
he spit,
like projectile almond,
like flew and hit Steve in the face.
I have the blooper clip.
We're going to need a signal
to bolt out of there,
the slightest sign of danger.
在他的大笑中，他喷了，就像喷射出的杏仁，飞出来打在了史蒂夫的脸上。我有那个NG片段。我们需要一个信号来冲出那里，哪怕有一点点危险的迹象。
Oh,
okay,
and that signal is lit your lips.
Let me see him.
No, no,
like this.
Oh, dude, I'm so sorry.
Oh, I'm so sorry, dude.
哦，好的，那个信号是舔你的嘴唇。让我看看他。不，不，像这样。哦，伙计，我很抱歉。哦，我很抱歉，伙计。
It's okay.
The side of his face with a wet, half-chewed almonds.
I mean, you can hear it come out of his mouth.
You really can.
And then Rain felt so bad, and he grabs like a tissue,
and he starts in the moment just reacted.
He just starts wiping Steve's face.
Oh, my gosh.
没关系。他脸的一侧沾着湿漉漉、嚼了一半的杏仁。我的意思是，你可以听到它从他嘴里喷出来。你真的可以。然后雷恩感到非常抱歉，他抓起一张纸巾，在那一刻做出了反应。他开始擦史蒂夫的脸。哦，天哪。
It's so good.
Michael then has a talking head where he says
that in nature, there is a food chain where the bigger shark, eats the littler shark, and so on.
Until it gets to the single-cell shark.
Exactly.
And basically, you know, that's what they are.
They're sharks.
太棒了。太棒了。迈克尔随后有一个采访镜头，他说在自然界中，有一个食物链，大鲨鱼吃小鲨鱼，以此类推。直到变成单细胞鲨鱼。正是如此。基本上，你知道，他们就是那样。他们是鲨鱼。
And then as he's getting out of the car, he's doing the whole Jaws theme.
Yeah.
He goes into Prince Family Paper.
He introduces himself as Michael Scarn, and he sits down and he's
starts having just the most wonderful conversation with Mr. Prince.
Michael's doing kind of a good job.
He is.
And, you know, he completely charms Mr. Prince.
然后当他下车时，他一直在哼《大白鲨》的主题曲。是的。他走进普林斯家族纸业公司。他介绍自己是迈克尔·斯卡恩，他坐下来，开始与普林斯先生进行最美妙的谈话。迈克尔做得还不错。他是。而且，你知道，他完全迷住了普林斯先生。
He does.
He's a lawyer who knows a lot about paper because he is a genius.
Yes.
About some things, but not everything.
Not everything.
What's this?
Is this a phone?
他确实做到了。他是一个非常了解纸张的律师，因为他是个天才。是的。关于某些事情，但不是所有事情。不是所有事情。这是什么？这是电话吗？这是电话吗？
Mr. Roger Prince can't get enough of it.
He's cackling, laughing.
He also learns that Prince Family Paper is a three-person operation.
Yeah.
Mr. Prince, his wife, Linda, and his son.
Yes.
And his granddaughter, Rebecca, sits in the corner.
Angela, I did a guest star breakdown for the members of Prince Family Paper.
罗杰·普林斯先生对此爱不释手。他咯咯地笑着。他还了解到普林斯家族纸业是一家三口经营的公司。是的。普林斯先生，他的妻子琳达，还有他的儿子。是的。他的孙女丽贝卡坐在角落里。安吉拉，我为普林斯家族纸业的成员做了一个客串演员分析。
Oh, great.
So Roger Prince, the father, was played by Dan Desmond.
And I found this really interesting.
From 1990 to 2001, he was in five different.
episodes of Law and Order, and he played a different character each time.
Let me tell you, I love Law and Order, and they do that.
They bring people back. One time you're a police officer, the next time you're a judge.
I was literally just watching a Law and Order Marathon, and I swear, Jeremy Sisto was like
哦，太好了。所以罗杰·普林斯，父亲，由丹·德斯蒙德饰演。我发现这非常有趣。从1990年到2001年，他出演了五集不同的《法律与秩序》，每次都扮演不同的角色。让我告诉你，我喜欢《法律与秩序》，他们就是那样做的。他们让人们回来。有一次你是警察，下一次你是法官。我刚才还在看《法律与秩序》马拉松，我发誓，杰里米·西斯托就像
just a guest star, like a guy, and then in the next episode, he was a police officer in like
a series regular. No, I don't doubt. Did that happen? I feel like the rules of Law and Order are
sort of like a soap opera. Yeah. You can come back in many different forms. Well, they loved
Dan Desmond over at Law and Order. He was also in the movie Bruce Almighty and most recently in the
miniseries Little Fires Everywhere. Gung-gung. Roger Prince Jr. was played by Dan Bacendal.
You might recognize him for his recurring roles on Veep or the Goldbergs or Space Force. He was also a
regular on life and pieces, he has also been on Law and Order, but just one episode.
Okay.
只是一个客串明星，像个路人，然后在下一集中，他就是一名警察，还是系列常驻演员。不，我不怀疑。那发生了吗？我觉得《法律与秩序》的规则有点像肥皂剧。是的。你可以以许多不同的形式回来。好吧，他们在《法律与秩序》里很喜欢丹·德斯蒙德。他还出演了电影《冒牌天神》，最近还出演了迷你剧《星星之火》。冈冈。罗杰·普林斯二世由丹·巴森达尔饰演。你可能因为他在《副总统》、《戈德堡一家》或《太空部队》中的常驻角色而认出他。他也是《生活碎片》的常驻演员，他也上过《法律与秩序》，但只有一集。好的。
Linda Price was played by Sharon Blackwood, who recently appeared in two episodes of Ozark,
has never been on Law & Order.
None of them have been on Monk.
What?
None.
Craziness.
Okay, wait, I have a Law & Order story.
What is it?
琳达·普林斯由莎伦·布莱克伍德饰演，她最近出现在两集《黑钱胜地》中，从未上过《法律与秩序》。他们中没有人上过《神探阿蒙》。什么？一个都没有。太疯狂了。好吧，等等，我有一个《法律与秩序》的故事。是什么？
It's one of my more embarrassing audition stories.
You auditioned for Law and Order?
I did.
Shocker didn't get it. You'll know why. You guys, I was so excited. I love Law & Order. I would watch the
marathon on T&T. I loved it. Yeah, same. I still watch the marathon. I still watch it. If it's on,
I'm watching it. All right. I got an audition. I was so excited. And I was very new to auditioning.
Okay? I'd only booked a few commercials. It was to be a real estate agent. You know how the guys at the top of the show would, like,
like interview people while they were at work.
这是我最尴尬的试镜故事之一。你试镜过《法律与秩序》？我试过。令人震惊的是没选上。你会知道原因的。伙计们，我太兴奋了。我喜欢《法律与秩序》。我会在TNT上看马拉松。我喜欢它。是的，我也是。我仍然看马拉松。我仍然看它。如果它在播，我就在看。好吧。我得到了一个试镜。我太兴奋了。而且我对试镜非常陌生。好吧？我只预订过几个广告。那是演一个房地产经纪人。你知道节目开头的人会，比如，在人们工作时采访他们。
And they're always too busy.
They're always too busy.
I got to get somewhere.
Yeah, yeah.
Like this murder you're investigating is a big inconvenience to me.
I have to show a house.
Yeah, exactly.
Are we done?
他们总是太忙了。他们总是太忙了。我得去个地方。是的，是的。就像你正在调查的这起谋杀案对我来说是个大麻烦。我得去带人看房。是的，完全正确。我们完了吗？
Exactly.
I had just watched an episode where they were questioning these guys that were loading trash into like a garbage truck.
Yep.
They did not stop loading their trash.
No.
They're going to keep.
They're annoyed.
我们完了吗？完全正确。我刚看了一集，他们正在盘问那些把垃圾装进垃圾车的人。是的。他们没有停止装垃圾。不。他们要继续。他们很烦。
I'm busy here.
I got to keep the truck moving.
Always.
I had this in my brain.
In the script, it said, they question a real estate agent as she is setting out her signs for the day with the little flag, her showing signs.
Yeah, right?
You know those things.
我很忙。我得让车继续走。总是这样。总是这样。我脑子里有这个。在剧本里，它说，他们盘问一个房地产经纪人，当时她正在为这一天摆放她的标志，那些小旗子，她的展示标志。是的，对吧？你知道那些东西。
Lady, I'm not even joking.
I think I literally just saw this episode.
Are you kidding?
Yeah, there was a blonde woman and she had to be blonde because that was part of the plot.
Yeah.
By the way.
And she was talking to them while putting out the little sign for selling the house.
女士，我甚至不是在开玩笑。我想我刚才真的看了这一集。你在开玩笑吗？是的，有一个金发女人，她必须是金发，因为那是情节的一部分。是的。顺便说一句。是的。她一边和他们说话，一边摆放卖房的小标志。
Okay. Oh my God, I saw the part you didn't get. Okay. So I go in there and I'm like, okay, I got this. So it's a casting agent. She's sitting across from her desk. I was so nervous, but I was like, I got this. I got this. Literally, it's three lines. It's like three or four lines. That's it. All I had in my brain was, you will not interrupt me from putting out my real estate sign. Yeah. That's the energy. Jenna in this woman's office, I moved two chairs out of my way. Her chairs! Her chairs! Her chairs! Her chair.
Cheers. We had to put up your sign. I moved them. And then when we started the scene, I am setting
things out. Setting it out. Moving things. Busy. Busy. I'm moving things. And it must have been really
distracting. She said, you know what? I'm going to stop you. Oh, no. You never want to hear that in an audition.
No. She was like, you're doing too much. Okay. You're doing too much. Stop moving things around and just
deliver the lines. And I said, okay, this went into my brain as don't touch.
her chairs, but do some great space work. Yeah, mime it. Now I mime putting out real estate signs. Mime, mime, mime, mime, mime, mime. I must have just looked ridiculous. Yeah. I didn't get the part. I did too much business. You know who's been on Law & Order? Who? Rain Wilson. He plays a creepy janitor. Oh, I need to see it. During one of my marathons, I was just sitting there and I was like, oh, it's rain. Rain, there he is. You know,
Who else has been on Jackie DeBotton?
好的。天哪，我看到了你没选上的那部分。好的。所以我进去，我想，好的，我搞定了。所以这是一个选角代理。她坐在她的办公桌对面。我太紧张了，但我对自己说，我搞定了。我搞定了。字面上，只有三行台词。只有三或四行。就是这样。我脑子里只有，你不能打断我摆放我的房地产标志。是的。就是那种能量。珍娜，在这个女人的办公室里，我把两把椅子移开了。她的椅子！她的椅子！她的椅子！她的椅子。干杯。我们得竖起你的标志。我移开了它们。然后当我们开始这一幕时，我正在摆放东西。摆放它。移动东西。忙碌。忙碌。我正在移动东西。这一定非常令人分心。她说，你知道吗？我要叫停你。哦，不。你永远不想在试镜中听到那个。不。她说，你做得太多了。好的。你做得太多了。停止移动东西，只管念台词。我说，好的，这进入我的大脑，变成了不要碰她的椅子，但要做一些很棒的空间工作。是的，模仿它。现在我模仿摆放房地产标志。模仿，模仿，模仿，模仿，模仿，模仿。我一定看起来很荒谬。是的。我没得到那个角色。我做了太多的动作。你知道谁上过《法律与秩序》吗？谁？雷恩·威尔逊。他扮演一个令人毛骨悚然的清洁工。哦，我得看看。在我的一次马拉松期间，我只是坐在那里，我想，哦，是雷恩。雷恩，他就在那儿。你知道，还有谁上过？杰基·德巴顿。
Ah!
Yeah, she was just on in the marathon I watched.
Jackie!
Well, if I ever get to audition for Law and Order again, I'm not going to do a lot of business.
Don't do it.
Finally, Rebecca Prince, the little girl, was played by Emily Evan Ray, and she's going to come back in a couple of episodes, actually.
Emily recently produced and directed a documentary called Stop the Bleed about the mass shooting in Parkland, Florida.
My gosh.
啊！是的，她就在我看的马拉松里。杰基！好吧，如果我还有机会试镜《法律与秩序》，我不会做太多的动作。别做。最后，丽贝卡·普林斯，那个小女孩，由艾米丽·埃文·雷饰演，她实际上会在几集后回来。艾米丽最近制作并导演了一部名为《停止流血》的纪录片，关于佛罗里达州帕克兰的大规模枪击事件。天哪。
Emily was born and raised in Parkland, and she made the movie to give a voice to the family, friends, and the community who were affected.
She won the audience award at the Fort Lauderdale Film Festival for Best Documentary.
Wow.
Yeah, that's what she's been up to.
That's amazing.
Yes.
Well, on that note, I think we should take a break, and then we'll be back to join the group at Dunder Mifflin, because they have more to say.
There's a big debate going on.
艾米丽在帕克兰出生长大，她制作这部电影是为了给受影响的家人、朋友和社区发声。她赢得了劳德代尔堡电影节的最佳纪录片观众奖。哇。是的，这就是她一直在做的事情。太棒了。是的。好吧，说到这里，我想我们应该休息一下，然后我们会回来加入邓德·米夫林的团队，因为他们还有更多的话要说。正在进行一场大辩论。
Well, we're back in the bullpen.
Okay.
And the debate is still going on, the hot or not, there's a whole debate about what is attractive hot.
Right.
Kevin has a lot to say.
The most ever.
But first, Jim is going to comment that, you know, sometimes we forget to think of celebrities as real people.
Kevin sort of says it's a gut thing, right?
好吧，我们回到了办公室。好的。辩论还在继续，关于“火辣还是不火辣”，关于什么是吸引人的火辣，有一场大辩论。对。凯文有很多话要说。有史以来最多。但首先，吉姆会评论说，你知道，有时我们忘记把名人当作真实的人。凯文说这是一种直觉，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
And then Jim gets all up in Kevin's ear and gives like a husky whisper.
Like a sultry paints a picture of Hillary Swank coming.
up to him. We got so much mail about John Krasinski's husky voice to Kevin in this episode.
It was like, just, I was too shy to put it in my document. Oh, come on. Give me one nugget. Something you
remember someone saying. One nugget. Basically, this woman said, what? John Krasinski could
debate anything in my ear if he uses that voice.
It was so funny to me.
嗯哼。然后吉姆凑到凯文耳边，用沙哑的声音低语。像一种性感的描绘，描绘希拉里·斯万克向他走来。我们收到了很多关于约翰·卡拉辛斯基在这一集中对凯文的沙哑声音的邮件。就像，我太害羞了，没把它放进我的文档里。哦，得了吧。给我一个片段。你记得有人说的什么。一个片段。基本上，这个女人说，什么？如果约翰·卡拉辛斯基用那种声音，他可以在我耳边辩论任何事情。这对我来说太搞笑了。
But I did write down this one because Laura B needed a soapbox moment, so I thought I'd give it to her.
Okay, Laura.
Laura says this, it always bothers me that when Stanley asks why they're making a distinction between beautiful and hot, Kevin says, quote, a painting can be beautiful, but I don't want to bang a painting.
But later in the episode, Kevin turns around and tells Jim to respect the.
the game after Jim narrates the saucy scenario with Hillary Swank, and Kevin says, no, it's, is she hot?
Not would you bang her? But he just used the same phrase to explain why he wouldn't bang a painting.
Kevin, you can't use the same argument on different sides. That's what Laura B says. She says,
you respect the game, Kevin. Yeah, Kevin. Laura, we hear you.
但我确实写下了这一条，因为劳拉·B需要一个发表意见的机会，所以我想给她。好的，劳拉。劳拉说这个，这总是困扰我，当斯坦利问为什么他们要在美丽和火辣之间做区分时，凯文说，引用，“一幅画可以是美丽的，但我不想和一幅画发生关系。”但后来在这一集中，凯文转过身告诉吉姆要“尊重游戏”，在吉姆叙述了与希拉里·斯万克的性感场景之后，凯文说，不，是，她火辣吗？不是你会和她发生关系吗？但他刚才用了同样的短语来解释为什么他不会和一幅画发生关系。凯文，你不能在不同的立场上使用同样的论点。这就是劳拉·B说的。她说，你尊重游戏，凯文。是的，凯文。劳拉，我们听到了。
Angela has been over in accounting. She hasn't wanted to participate, but she can't take it anymore.
All right? Kevin holding court like this, she's had it. She gets up and she says,
okay, I wasn't going to dignify this discussion by getting involved, but I don't even get the discussion.
Hot is a temperature, people, but Kevin deserves to lose for what he said. So yes, she's hot. She's hot as heck.
She's a female Boris Becker.
I love that Boris Becker is it for Angela Martin. Who knew? I know. I didn't even realize Angela Martin was a tennis fan. Clearly? Yeah. Well, y'all, Boris Becker was a German tennis player who shot to start him when he won the Wimbledon men's singles title in 1985. It was significant because he was only 17 years old and he was the first unseated player and the first German to win.
win the Wimbledon singles title, as well as the youngest ever male Grand Slam singles champion.
It was huge. I watched it with my mom. My mom's a big, big tennis player. She's phenomenal.
安吉拉一直在会计部。她不想参与，但她受够了。好吧？凯文这样主持大局，她受够了。她站起来说，好的，我本来不想通过参与来降低这场讨论的档次，但我甚至不明白这场讨论。火辣是一个温度，伙计们，但凯文因为他说的话应该输。所以是的，她很火辣。她火辣得要命。她是女版的鲍里斯·贝克尔。我喜欢鲍里斯·贝克尔是安吉拉·马丁的菜。谁知道呢？我知道。我甚至没意识到安吉拉·马丁是网球迷。显然？是的。好吧，各位，鲍里斯·贝克尔是一位德国网球运动员，他在1985年赢得温布尔登男子单打冠军时一举成名。这很重要，因为他只有17岁，他是第一个非种子选手，也是第一个赢得温布尔登单打冠军的德国人，同时也是有史以来最年轻的男子大满贯单打冠军。这太大了。我和我妈妈一起看的。我妈妈是个超级网球迷。她很了不起。
She was ranked by the USDA by her age group. I spent my whole childhood on a tennis court.
Wow. Yeah. My mom is like, I did not know that about your mom. My mom's a badass tennis player.
We're a big tennis family, guys. There are two things that are always on at our house,
either the weather or tennis, because my mom has the tennis channel. Yeah. And we'll watch
Old games. Oh, I'd love it when Boris Becker would play Stefan Eggberg because my mom had shown me old games of Beyond Borg and he was the other big swede. There was Stefan and Beyond Borg. And Beyond Borg would play John McEnroe. Speaking of, Boris Becker played John McEnroe. And it's one of the longest games in tennis history. It was the Davis Cup. It was six hours. Can you imagine playing tennis for six hours? No. Unbelievable. I can't imagine playing tennis for six minutes.
So anyway, Boris Becker does it for Angela Martin.
I think we should go back to Prince family paper, lady.
We forgot to mention that Dwight has come in.
她曾被美国网球协会按年龄组排名。我的整个童年都在网球场上度过。哇。是的。我妈妈就像，我不知道你妈妈的事。我妈妈是个厉害的网球运动员。我们是一个网球大家庭，伙计们。我们家总是有两样东西在播，要么是天气，要么是网球，因为我妈妈有网球频道。是的。我们会看旧比赛。哦，我喜欢鲍里斯·贝克尔和斯特凡·埃德伯格比赛的时候，因为我妈妈给我看过比约恩·博格的旧比赛，他是另一个伟大的瑞典人。有斯特凡和比约恩·博格。比约恩·博格会和约翰·麦肯罗比赛。说到这个，鲍里斯·贝克尔和约翰·麦肯罗比赛过。这是网球史上最长的比赛之一。那是戴维斯杯。打了六个小时。你能想象打六个小时网球吗？不。难以置信。我无法想象打六分钟网球。所以总之，鲍里斯·贝克尔是安吉拉·马丁的菜。我想我们应该回到普林斯家族纸业，女士。我们忘了提德怀特进去了。
He's going to pretend to get a job there.
He says, fire your son.
I'll be your son.
You can visit him on the weekends.
I know.
He comes in like a bowl in a china cabinet.
And he's going to explain to Mr. Prince just how awful his current boss.
is, you know, because he says, why are you looking for a new job? And he's like, well, my current
他要假装去那里找工作。他说，解雇你的儿子。我会成为你的儿子。你可以在周末去看他。我知道。他像一头公牛闯进瓷器店一样进来了。他要向普林斯先生解释他现在的老板有多糟糕，你知道，因为他说，你为什么要找新工作？他说，嗯，我现在的
boss is cruel. Terrible. Meanwhile, Michael's kind of walking around. He wants to get a photograph of
their kind of territory map over there by Mrs. Prince. Yeah. And then he offers to help her granddaughter
with a math problem. I have to say when I was watching these scenes, I was just so impressed with the
detail that went in to this little set. I know. Well, I was emailing with Michael Gallenberg about this
particular set, and he said everything you see, they had to bring in. Crazy. Crazy. I loved all the
details, too. Well, I noticed on that little girl's desk, did you see it? She had her own nameplate.
I know. It says Rebecca. I know. And also on the desk are all of these little, like,
hand-painted ceramic animals, like the kind that your granddaughter would give to you.
老板很残忍。太可怕了。与此同时，迈克尔在四处走动。他想拍一张他们在普林斯夫人那边的领土图。是的。然后他主动提出帮她的孙女解决一道数学题。我必须说，当我观看这些场景时，我对这个小布景所投入的细节印象深刻。我知道。好吧，我正在和迈克尔·加伦伯格通过电子邮件讨论这个特定的布景，他说你看到的一切，他们都必须带进来。疯狂。疯狂。我也喜欢所有的细节。好吧，我注意到那个小女孩的桌子上，你看到了吗？她有自己的名牌。我知道。上面写着丽贝卡。我知道。而且桌子上还有所有这些小小的，像手绘的陶瓷动物，就像你孙女会给你的那种。
And also I noticed on the wall there was one of those photo collages, love framed photos.
They had clearly asked the actors to bring in some pictures.
And all of those details to me just like really set this up as a family business.
And it made the whole storyline even more heartbreaking.
No, they had a whole family photo wall.
I zoomed in.
One is like a wedding photo.
And then there's like your grandson in his baseball uniform holding his baseball bat.
而且我还注意到墙上有一张照片拼贴画，爱装裱的照片。他们显然要求演员们带一些照片来。所有这些细节对我来说真的把这设定为一个家族企业。这让整个故事情节更加令人心碎。不，他们有一整面家庭照片墙。我放大了。一张是婚礼照片。然后还有你孙子穿着棒球服拿着棒球棒的照片。
Yeah.
And then there was a big paint.
like your kids do at preschool where they take their hands and put it in paint and then they make their handprints into flowers.
Yes.
Just like the most amazing details.
I feel like this is Michael's true dream office because it is a real family.
Yes, Angela, you're so right.
He wants his office to be his family.
是的。然后还有一张大画，就像你孩子在幼儿园做的那样，他们把手放在颜料里，然后把手印做成花。是的。简直是最惊人的细节。我觉得这是迈克尔梦想中的办公室，因为它是一个真正的家庭。是的，安吉拉，你说得太对了。他希望他的办公室成为他的家庭。
And this office is a family.
I know.
Well, that's going to weigh on his heartstrings.
Well, as he wraps up his visit, he gets Mr. Prince to just hand him a list of their top clients.
Oh, Mr. Prince, he's just so trusting. He's like, listen, if you want to see we do a good job, here's all of our references. Here's all of our clients.
Well, Dwight and Michael immediately start licking their lips. Yeah. Time to get out of there. Time to get out of there.
Dwight says, sir, can you give me a ride home? Michael's like, yeah. And then they sprint. They walk.
Hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry to the car. Get out, peel out, peel out. Because they know they got all the info. Yes. Well, as they're trying to flee, Michael runs over like the parking curb. It's so funny. He runs over the bumper. That cement block. Yeah, I don't know what you call that thing. What do you call that? It's like a partition. It's like the cement block so you don't go into the other spot. I've done it. I've done it. But I haven't backed back over it. No, of course not. Once you realize you go over it, keep going.
而这个办公室就是一个家庭。我知道。好吧，那会让他心碎的。好吧，当他结束访问时，他让普林斯先生直接给了他一份他们的顶级客户名单。哦，普林斯先生，他太信任人了。他说，听着，如果你想看看我们做得好不好，这是我们所有的推荐人。这是我们所有的客户。好吧，德怀特和迈克尔立刻开始舔嘴唇。是的。是时候离开那里了。是时候离开那里了。德怀特说，先生，你能送我回家吗？迈克尔说，好的。然后他们冲刺。他们走。快，快，快，快，快去车里。出去，开走，开走。因为他们知道他们得到了所有的信息。是的。好吧，当他们试图逃跑时，迈克尔撞上了停车路缘。太搞笑了。他撞上了保险杠。那个水泥块。是的，我不知道你怎么称呼那个东西。你叫它什么？它就像一个隔板。它就像水泥块，这样你就不会进入另一个车位。我做过。我做过。但我没有倒车撞上去。不，当然没有。一旦你意识到你撞上去了，继续走。
Well, I asked Randy, how did we do this stunt?
What do you say?
He said we had two different identical cars, one that was totally normal and one that was
pre-rigged with a damaged bumper.
So Steve never damaged a car.
And if you notice, the camera stays inside the car on Dwight and Michael.
So what Steve was actually driving over were just a couple of sandbags.
Well, it totally sold it.
好吧，我问兰迪，我们是怎么做这个特技的？他说什么？他说我们有两辆完全相同的车，一辆是完全正常的，另一辆是预先装好损坏保险杠的。所以史蒂夫从来没有损坏过车。如果你注意到，摄像机一直留在车内拍摄德怀特和迈克尔。所以史蒂夫实际上开车压过的是几个沙袋。好吧，它完全卖座了。
It did.
and they had to add all that kind of crunching effect in editing.
So, yeah, faky cement thing was actually sandbags and sound effects.
The Prince family hears this commotion, and they come running out.
And of course, Mr. Prince, because he's so sweet, offers to fix the bumper.
And they're like, no, no, no, wait, no, please let us.
We'll get a tow truck.
And he's like, oh, no, they're too expensive.
确实。他们必须在剪辑中添加所有那种挤压效果。所以，假水泥东西实际上是沙袋和音效。普林斯一家听到了这种骚动，他们跑了出来。当然，普林斯先生，因为他太甜了，主动提出修理保险杠。他们说，不，不，不，等等，不，请让我们来。我们会叫拖车。他说，哦，不，它们太贵了。
I got it.
And Jenna, this scene made me think of my dad.
It made me think of my dad, too, because of the duct tape.
My dad would fix anything with duct tape.
Same!
My dad did this with my first car.
The handle on my glove box broke.
Okay.
我来弄。珍娜，这一幕让我想起了我爸爸。它也让我想起了我爸爸，因为胶带。我爸爸会用胶带修理任何东西。我也是！我爸爸用我的第一辆车做了这个。我手套箱的把手坏了。好的。
My dad duct taped it.
You know what it's making me think of?
What?
Josh's duct tape is zip ties.
All over the house.
Your husband zip ties it?
Our dads would duct tape it.
Yeah.
我爸爸用胶带粘住了。你知道它让我想起什么吗？什么？乔什的胶带是扎带。到处都是。你丈夫用扎带？我们爸爸会用胶带。是的。
My dishwasher tray has been zip tied for four years.
It finally fell apart.
We had to get a new dishwasher.
But you can pretty much fix anything with duct tape.
Pretty much, including a whole bumper. So now they're in the car, they're going to head back.
Dwight still is celebrating. He wants to do high fives. He calls them the sucker family.
I know. Dwight is that like young kid on the soccer field who doesn't know when to stop?
Yeah. Like you scored the goal and now stop taunting. Yeah. All right? Exactly.
我的洗碗机托盘已经被扎带绑了四年了。它终于散架了。我们不得不买一台新洗碗机。但你几乎可以用胶带修理任何东西。几乎，包括整个保险杠。所以现在他们在车里，他们要回去了。德怀特还在庆祝。他想击掌。他称他们为“傻瓜家庭”。我知道。德怀特就像足球场上那个不知道什么时候该停下来的小孩子？是的。就像你进了球，现在别再嘲讽了。是的。好吧？完全正确。
Michael is having some regrets. Yeah. Dwight tries to high five Michael and Michael's like not having any of it.
So back in the office, Toby is studying Hillary Swank.
Pam was going to make a speech.
She's going to appeal to the ladies of the office.
Yeah.
What?
Are we going to let the Kevins of the world decide things for us?
And then Oscar projects this picture of Hillary Swank's face with all this grid on it, right?
迈克尔有一些遗憾。是的。德怀特试图和迈克尔击掌，迈克尔根本不理会。所以回到办公室，托比正在研究希拉里·斯万克。帕姆要发表讲话。她要呼吁办公室的女士们。是的。什么？我们要让世界上的凯文们为我们做决定吗？然后奥斯卡投射了这张希拉里·斯万克的脸，上面有所有这些网格，对吧？
Yeah.
And he talks about coinophilia.
The symmetry, right, of the face?
So coinophilia is.
this, stay with me here, evolutionary hypothesis for explaining why certain animals seek mates that
look a certain way, and it proposes that animals, including humans, find the symmetry of features
most attractive.
I read all about it.
是的。他谈到了“平均脸”。对称性，对吧？所以平均脸是这个，跟我来，解释为什么某些动物寻找看起来像某种样子的配偶的进化假设，它提出动物，包括人类，发现特征的对称性最吸引人。我读了所有关于它的内容。
I barely understood it.
Okay.
It was very wordy.
But in ancient Greece, they created something called the golden ratio of the golden ratio
of beauty or phi. It's a mathematical equation and it says if your face possesses a specific set of
ratios of distance between the different features on your face, they believed it could be
mathematically proven that you had a perfect face. This equation is what Da Vinci used when he was
creating his Vertruvian man. Oh.
我几乎没听懂。好的。它非常啰嗦。但在古希腊，他们创造了一种叫做“黄金比例”或“phi”的东西。这是一个数学方程，它说如果你的脸拥有特定的一组特征间距比例，他们相信可以从数学上证明你有一张完美的脸。这个方程就是达芬奇在创作他的维特鲁威人时使用的。哦。
That is what Oscars, I think, really talking about.
I think he's talking about ratios.
I don't think he's really talking about coinophilia.
Stanley's going to address the group, and he makes a really moving speech about how he's trying to be more optimistic in life.
And in years past, he might have been critical, but he's not going to be that person anymore.
No, I liked this speech.
I did too.
You know, he's saying, why are we doing this to one another?
这就是奥斯卡，我认为，真正谈论的。我认为他在谈论比例。我不认为他真的在谈论平均脸。斯坦利要向小组发表讲话，他发表了一段非常感人的演讲，关于他如何努力在生活中变得更乐观。在过去几年里，他可能很挑剔，但他不会再成为那样的人了。不，我喜欢这个演讲。我也喜欢。你知道，他说，我们为什么要对彼此这样做？
Let's just live our lives, basically.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. Andy calls for a final vote on Hillary Swank's hotness. It's another tie. We discover like this is what happens. People just argue their position. They don't listen. That's what Oscar says. Yeah, no one's moved. No one's moving. But Michael gets back to the office during all of this. He's clearly worked up. He goes in his office with Dwight. They shut the door. He doesn't want to go through with it.
Yeah. Dwight knows that Michael is bailing. So he's going to try his best to convince Michael that what they did was right. And of course, he's going to use the one argument that will clearly point this out to Michael, which is a Lord of the Rings analogy.
Dwight says there was a terrible war. Oh, so many died. Far too many died. But if Frodo hadn't destroyed the ring, then goodness itself might have died.
I didn't understand that. I was Michael.
I have questions. I wrote them down. Okay, I thought you might. Listen, I am not a Lord of the Rings expert. I don't want to get mail, guys. I just am a fan. I've seen the movies multiple times. I've read some of the books. It's a big commitment to get through them all. Okay. I have not gotten through them all.
Okay. Well, here's my first question. Okay. Who is the Lord of the Rings? Okay. Is it Frodo? No. Is it the guy with the beard?
让我们过我们的生活，基本上。嗯哼。是的。安迪要求对希拉里·斯万克的火辣程度进行最终投票。又是平局。我们发现这就是发生的事情。人们只是争论他们的立场。他们不听。这就是奥斯卡说的。是的，没有人被说服。没有人动摇。但迈克尔在这一切期间回到了办公室。他显然很激动。他和德怀特进了他的办公室。他们关上了门。他不想继续下去了。是的。德怀特知道迈克尔要退出了。所以他要尽力说服迈克尔他们所做的是对的。当然，他要使用一个能清楚地向迈克尔指出这一点的论点，那就是《指环王》的类比。德怀特说有一场可怕的战争。哦，死了太多人了。死得太多了。但如果弗罗多没有摧毁戒指，那么善良本身可能就死了。我不明白。我是迈克尔。我有问题。我把它们写下来了。好的，我想你可能会。听着，我不是《指环王》专家。我不想收到邮件，伙计们。我只是一个粉丝。我看过很多次电影。我读过一些书。看完所有书是一个很大的承诺。好的。我还没看完。好的。好吧，这是我的第一个问题。好的。谁是《指环王》？好的。是弗罗多吗？不。是那个留胡子的人吗？
No, it's not like a one person. What is the ring? Well, it's called the One Ring, right? The One Ring to rule.
them all. Okay. Oh, Lord. Okay. All right. Where do I even start? First of all, here's what I want to say. I know the
battle that Dwight's referencing. I'm pretty sure it's the battle of the Black Gate, right? Which is the big,
major battle for the War of the Ring. They fought it right in front of the gate. And they were trying to
distract the Eye of Saron because the Eye of Saran tracks whoever holds the ring. And Frodo had the
ring and Frodo was trying to get to Mount Doom to drop it into the lava lake thing, right? That's the
place it can be destroyed. Why do you have to get rid of it? Why is he destroying it? Okay, because it's
innately evil. I'll explain. Okay. So it's called the Lord of the Rings, but it's one ring.
不，它不像是一个人。什么是戒指？嗯，它叫至尊魔戒，对吧？至尊魔戒，统御众戒。好的。哦，天哪。好的。好吧，我从哪里开始？首先，这是我想说的。我知道德怀特提到的战斗。我很确定是黑门之战，对吧？这是魔戒战争中最大、最重要的战斗。他们在门前战斗。他们试图分散索伦之眼的注意力，因为索伦之眼会追踪任何持有戒指的人。弗罗多有戒指，弗罗多正试图到达末日火山把它扔进熔岩湖里，对吧？那是可以摧毁它的地方。你为什么要摆脱它？他为什么要摧毁它？好的，因为它本质上是邪恶的。我会解释。好的。所以它叫《指环王》，但它是一枚戒指。
So it shouldn't be, why, it's not called Lord of the Ring. Okay. Okay. Okay. So Bill Bowdo Bagan's, right?
Oh my God. He found the ring. Gollum had been hiding it. This is a really bad overview from me.
Anyway, he gave it to Frodo.
And, you know, Gandalf realized that Bill Baggins, like, when he had the ring, it kind of made him a different person.
So Gandalf was like, something's up with that, you know.
But there was this inscription when you take the ring and you put it in the fire, because just fire can't kill it.
Dragon Fire can't kill it.
Not even Dragon Fire?
所以它不应该，为什么，它不叫《指环王》。好的。好的。好的。所以比尔博·巴金斯，对吧？哦，天哪。他发现了戒指。咕噜一直把它藏起来。这对我来说是一个非常糟糕的概述。总之，他把它给了弗罗多。而且，你知道，甘道夫意识到比尔博·巴金斯，就像，当他有戒指时，它让他变成了一个不同的人。所以甘道夫就像，那东西有点不对劲，你知道。但当你在火中放入戒指时，有一个铭文，因为火不能杀死它。龙火不能杀死它。连龙火都不行？
No, no, won't melt the ring.
But when you put it like in the fire, it has an inscription and it's written, I think is it an elfish guy?
Okay, don't write me.
I believe so.
Thank you, Sam.
When it's translated, the inscription says, and I did look this up, so I got it right,
one ring to rule them all, one ring to find them, one ring to bring them all, and in the darkness, bind them.
So the ring is essentially evil in nature, because it's an extension of Sauron, okay?
不，不，融化不了戒指。但当你把它放进火里时，它有一个铭文，它是用，我想是精灵语写的吗？好的，别写信给我。我相信是这样。谢谢，萨姆。当它被翻译时，铭文说，我确实查过，所以我弄对了，“至尊魔戒，统御众戒，至尊魔戒，寻觅众戒，至尊魔戒，唤醒众戒，在黑暗中，禁锢众戒。”所以戒指本质上是邪恶的，因为它是索伦的延伸，好的？
And Sauron's like bad.
He's bad, bad, bad.
But anyway, Frodo ultimately, you know, puts it in the lava lake thing.
and it finally is destroyed.
So lava is hotter than dragon fire.
Well, no, it had to go to Mount Doom specifically.
It's a special lava.
Because that's where Sauron made it.
而且索伦就像坏。他坏，坏，坏。但总之，弗罗多最终，你知道，把它放进了熔岩湖里。它终于被摧毁了。所以熔岩比龙火更热。嗯，不，它必须专门去末日火山。那是一种特殊的熔岩。因为那是索伦制造它的地方。
Oh, so it had to go back to where it came from.
Right.
Sort of.
Yeah.
It could only sort of melt into its original source material.
Yeah, I think so.
Here's a cool thing.
Can I just, before I know we're talking about the ring, but at the end of this,
哦，所以它必须回到它来的地方。对。某种程度上。是的。它只能某种程度上融化回它的原始源材料。是的，我想是这样。这是一个很酷的事情。我可以，我知道我们在谈论戒指，但在最后，
are you going to tell me who the Lord is.
the rings is. No, because
it's not one lord.
It's not one lord. Sam.
Okay, so originally they make
a bunch of rings. Yes.
There's like nine
for the men, some for the elves,
你要告诉我谁是魔戒之主吗？不，因为不是一个主。不是一个主。萨姆。好的，所以最初他们制造了一堆戒指。是的。有九个给人类，一些给精灵，
some for the dwarves. Then the one
ring can rule them all. That's what makes
it so dangerous. Right. And I guess
I mean, technically the lord
of all the rings would be Soron,
who made it. Well, because
he made the one ring. Yes. If you
were to get this ring, you would be the
一些给矮人。然后至尊魔戒可以统御它们。这就是它如此危险的原因。对。我想，我的意思是，从技术上讲，所有戒指的主人将是索伦，他制造了它。好吧，因为他制造了至尊魔戒。是的。如果你得到了这枚戒指，你就是
Lord of all the Rings, but it will corrupt you and make you evil.
It will corrupt you. It's what happens. It damages people.
Smeagle the Gollum. It'll cripple you. The humans, it makes them like crazy.
Yeah, it makes you insane and murderous and jealous and awful. I mean, that sounded good,
actually, Sam, that was, you made that interesting. Oh my God. I'm sitting right here.
I mean, I was like, while I was listening to that, I was like, huh, that sounds like really Shakespearean and
sort of like maybe I'd like it. Maybe read the books. Maybe you'd like the books better.
than movies because you lose interest when things get fantastical, and you could just flip a few pages past that.
指环王，但它会腐蚀你，让你变邪恶。它会腐蚀你。事情就是这样。它会伤害人。斯密戈，也就是咕噜。它会让你残废。人类，它让他们变得疯狂。是的，它让你变得疯狂、嗜杀、嫉妒且糟糕。我是说，那听起来不错，真的，山姆，你让它变得很有趣。天哪。我就坐在这儿。我是说，当我在听的时候，我在想，嗯，那听起来真的很莎士比亚，也许我会喜欢。也许读读原著吧。也许你会比电影更喜欢书，因为当情节变得奇幻时你就会失去兴趣，而你可以直接跳过那几页。
I don't know.
Well, Michael is not moved by Dwight's Lord of the Rings logic.
Yeah.
Like you, he's like, no, I don't know.
Okay, whatever.
I mean, you know, he's going to sprint out of the office with the piece of paper.
He's going to destroy it.
I assumed he was going to run to the shredder?
我不知道。好吧，迈克尔并没有被德怀特的《指环王》逻辑所打动。是的。就像你一样，他觉得，不，我不知道。好吧，随便吧。我是说，你知道，他会拿着那张纸冲出办公室。他会毁掉它。我以为他是要跑去碎纸机那里？
Yeah.
No.
He runs all the way outside to his car.
But shoot, he forgot his keys.
Meanwhile, Dwight is chasing him, trying to get it from him.
He gets his keys and then goes back out.
And we know how elaborate it was to shoot that because all of those places, the stairwell, the hallway,
they're all in different locations, in different buildings.
是的。不。他一路跑到了外面的车里。但该死，他忘了带钥匙。与此同时，德怀特在追他，想从他手里抢过来。他拿到了钥匙，然后又跑了回去。我们知道拍摄那段戏有多复杂，因为所有那些地方，楼梯间、走廊，它们都在不同的地点，不同的建筑里。
Oh, yeah.
So they would have to reset up and then make those guys run and then move and set up and make those guys run.
They did such a good job of selling.
how tired they were because they only ever really had to run for short distances.
Right, right. It was not actually all tied together.
In the end, Dwight is like, Michael, you have to do this because if we don't do this, someone will do this to us.
It will happen. Yeah. Did you see the piles of faky snow outside in the parking lot?
I did. Nice touch, guys. Ultimately, Michael agrees to call Wallace and give him the prints paper client list.
哦，是的。所以他们必须重新布置，然后让那些人跑，然后再移动、布置，再让那些人跑。他们把那种疲惫感表现得太好了，因为他们实际上只需要跑很短的距离。对，对。它并不是真的连在一起的。最后，德怀特说，迈克尔，你必须这样做，因为如果我们不做，别人也会对我们这样做。这一定会发生。是的。你看到停车场外面那堆假雪了吗？看到了。干得漂亮，伙计们。最终，迈克尔同意给华莱士打电话，把打印纸客户名单交给他。
and he realizes he's not a shark.
No.
It broke my heart that he gave him the list.
I know.
I was really rooting for Michael to destroy the list.
There's going to be a callback to it.
It's brutal.
Brutal.
然后他意识到他不是一条鲨鱼。不。他把名单交出去让我心碎。我知道。我真的很支持迈克尔毁掉那份名单。后面会有个呼应。太残酷了。残酷。
Michael has a talking head.
He shares it's a bittersweet moment.
There was an alt-talking head.
I have to play it, guys.
It's in deleted scenes.
The last line of it made me spit out my ice tea as I was watching it.
Okay.
I've always been intrigued with the idea of ruling with an iron fist.
迈克尔有一个采访镜头。他分享说这是一个苦乐参半的时刻。有一个备选的采访镜头。我必须放出来，伙计们。它在删减片段里。最后一句台词让我看的时候把冰茶都喷出来了。好吧。我一直对用铁腕统治的想法很感兴趣。
And it is good for ruling.
But you know what it's not good for?
For caressing the face of a child.
Or making love to a woman with your hands.
Or thumb wrestling.
Or hanging out in the rain.
Or if you walk through a magnet store, you get covered in magnets.
Oh, well, I'm done.
这对于统治来说是好事。但你知道它不适合做什么吗？不适合抚摸孩子的脸。或者用你的手去爱抚一个女人。或者掰手腕。或者在雨中漫步。或者如果你走进一家磁铁店，你会被磁铁覆盖。哦，好吧，我受够了。
No more iron fisting for me.
Oh, ridiculous.
Get through that.
I don't know.
How did you get through the line about walking through a magnet store?
All of it.
It's so ridiculous.
我再也不要铁腕了。哦，太荒谬了。把它演完。我不知道。你是怎么忍住不笑把走进磁铁店那句台词说出来的？我不知道。所有这些。太荒谬了。
It made me laugh.
I was like, everybody needs to hear this.
How would they pick?
How would they?
All of these are so good.
How do they get in the editing room?
They have to pick one.
I don't know.
它让我笑了。我在想，每个人都需要听听这个。他们是怎么挑选的？他们怎么能？这些都太棒了。他们在剪辑室里是怎么做的？他们必须选一个。我不知道。
We have to ask Greg about that sometime.
I want to hear more.
about how they would pick things.
I mean, I know they would bring us in sometimes and ask our opinion,
but it feels like every episode they were having to make these decisions.
Well, Michael ends up ultimately being the tiebreaker, so we do have a winner.
Yes, he very casually says, she's hot.
Yeah.
我们得找个时间问问格雷格。我想听听更多关于他们如何挑选素材的事。我是说，我知道他们有时会把我们叫进去征求我们的意见，但感觉每一集他们都必须做出这些决定。好吧，迈克尔最终成为了决胜者，所以我们有了赢家。是的，他非常随意地说，她很辣。是的。
And then our team wins.
Our team won.
And we had a lot of tangents in this, guys.
We did.
We hope you enjoyed it.
This is just a window into our search history, guys.
You're welcome.
We will be back next week with stress relief, part one, and an epic cold open that I can't wait to talk about.
然后我们的团队赢了。我们的团队赢了。我们在这集里跑题了很多，伙计们。确实。我们希望你们喜欢。这只是你们窥探我们搜索历史的一个窗口，伙计们。不客气。下周我们将回来讨论《压力缓解》第一部分，还有一个我迫不及待想聊的史诗级开场。
Save Pandit!
I can't wait.
We'll see you next week.
See you next week.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
救救潘迪特！我等不及了。我们下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced.
by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Spotify, it's Jay Shetty.
Are you one of those media strategy people?
我们的《第二杯》剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。Spotify，是杰·谢蒂。你是那些媒体策略专家之一吗？
Scrolling through spreadsheets, searching for an audience
that pays twice as much attention to your ads
than they do on social?
Let me introduce you to fans.
And they're here with me on Spotify.
Trust me, I know fans.
They don't skip, they stay for hours.
They don't move on, they manifest.
翻阅电子表格，寻找那些对你的广告关注度比在社交媒体上高两倍的受众？让我为你介绍粉丝。他们就在Spotify上和我在一起。相信我，我了解粉丝。他们不会跳过，他们会停留数小时。他们不会离开，他们会显现。
They're not a demographic group.
They're fans.
Spotify advertising.
You're among fans.
Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
他们不是一个人口统计群体。他们是粉丝。Spotify广告。你在粉丝之中。嘿大家，我是凯莉·克拉克森，和Wayfair一起。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想，如果呢？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit Wayfair.ca.cair, every style, every home.
你应该从Wayfair订购。有了Wayfair，就没有如果。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的品质。访问Wayfair.ca，每种风格，每个家。